[Musique]
Clémence Marc bonsoir nous vous
retrouvons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement oui donc
Clémence Marc je suis docteur en
pharmacie également diplômé de HEC Paris
j'ai travaillé beaucoup dans le conseil
en stratégie donc dans deux cabinets qui
sont qui sont spécialisés qui
travaillent exclusivement avec la santé
et l'industrie pharmaceutique j'ai
également travaillé dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique donc dans deux
laboratoires à plein de fonctions
différentes donc je fais de la gestion
de projet du marketing des ventes
également j'étais au médical aussi sur
du développement de recherche clinique
ce qui m'a permis de toucher à pas mal
de fonctions dans ces industries
après ça j'ai été réserviste militaire
auprès du service de santé des armées et
depuis peu je travaille dans un cluster
industriel qui fédère en fait les sites
de production pharmaceutiques français
voilà ce qui pourrait représenter un
billet dans les analyses que je présente
même si ça fait longtemps que je
travaille sur le sujet bien avant d'y
travailler
et surtout je suis donc présidente d'une
association qui s'appelle adrastia une
association dans laquelle je suis
investie depuis 8 ans déjà maintenant
et qui est une association qui a été
créée par des citoyens en fait en 2014
donc
la motivation en fait de ses citoyens
pour créer l'association à brastia
c'était c'était un constat de déni de
déni généralisée face à toutes les
crises auxquelles l'humanité sont
confrontées donc on entend beaucoup
parler maintenant de la crise climatique
qui est particulièrement grave
c'était pas le cas à l'époque parce
qu'ils ont commencé à travailler sur le
projet en 2013 association montée en
2014 donc je sais pas s'il y en a qui se
rappelle mais le climat c'était pas
vraiment le premier sujet de
prédilection aux infos à cette époque
donc il y avait le climat mais il y a
aussi d'autres crises notamment la crise
des ressources donc ça aussi à l'époque
il y avait peu de personnes qui ont été
conscientes depuis il s'est passé quand
même pas mal de choses et je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui commencent à
comprendre la finitude de notre monde la
finitude d'un certain nombre de
ressources qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
minière qu'elle soit énergétique la
crise de la biodiversité aussi qui est
la plus méconnue je pense la plus mal
comprise et qui est à mon avis la
potentiellement la plus grave de toutes
beaucoup de scientifiques qui commencent
à qui commence à parler de ça puisque
c'est la crise de notre support de vie
la biodiversité c'est grâce à ça qu'on
est vivant tous ici et également une
autre crise qui est encore moins connue
je pense qui est la complexité
exponentielle en fait de nos sociétés
modernes thermo-industrielles
alors on va reparler de l'intrication du
modèle thermo industriel sur notre notre
petit pays voir notre petit continent
voir notre petit monde
première question adrastia président de
la drastia quand on objecte aux
effondristes entre guillemets que c'est
des
Cassandre que c'est des corbeaux que
c'est des oiseaux de mauvaise augure
surtout à partir de 2014 c'était des
maintenant ils sont un peu plus ils sont
un peu plus calmés mais
psychologiquement parlant vous qui
bossez avec votre assaut sur ce type de
sujet une façon relativement profonde
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'entendre ça de
gens ou qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce
que ça vous a fait
d'entendre ça vous avez l'impression en
face de vous d'avoir des
ça ça a vachement changé parce que si
tu te rappelles 2014 et ensuite
d'approvisionnement du covid comment ça
s'est géré ainsi de suite
une des particularités
à apporter des sujets des sujets
difficiles des sujets un petit peu
pourris de façon de façon il faut pas se
discréditer peut-être anxiogène je vous
répondrai je te l'accorderai c'est quand
même un sujet difficile parce que
globalement si tu te projettes à
l'époque 2014 tu parlais d'effondrement
tout le monde te regardait genre un
petit peu taré
et ça
donc tu pries comme traitement
ça a énormément changé ça a énormément
changé ça le regard sur sur cette notion
d'effondrement
souvent tu vois ce que j'ai envie de
dire aux gens l'effondrement c'est parce
que vous croyez parce qu'en fait alors
c'est un mot qui fait peur déjà et il y
a vraiment une enfin dans l'imaginaire
demain si tu veux il y a une association
avec avec l'Apocalypse hollywoodienne
l'effondrement ça a souvent été associé
à plein de films catastrophes et à une
espèce de d'apocalypse en genre 48
heures ou en trois jours et tout ça
l'effondrement alors ça pourrait être ça
on est d'accord mais globalement c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé dans le passé et
c'est probablement pas ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment
l'effondrement c'est c'est
un processus qui peut prendre qui peut
prendre des mois qui peut même prendre
des années
c'est un processus lent et nous nous
sommes des petits humains avec une
échelle de temps et de compréhension des
choses qui sont très courtes et donc en
fait à l'échelle de décennies c'est pas
quelque chose qui peut être ressenti
comme comme vraiment violent ou brutal
alors qu'en fait une société qui va
s'effondrer en 30 ou 50 ans si tu
regardes l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
déjà en fait hyper brutal et il perd et
hyper violent chez adracia nous on a
deux j'ai envie de te dire deux textes
fondateurs en fait de la pensée de
l'association le premier c'est le
rapport midoz je pense qu'il y a pas
besoin de le représenter à ta communauté
donc 1972 le rapport du Club de Rome qui
prévoyait alors qui a élaboré un certain
nombre de scénarios mais qui prévoyait
dans son scénario business à yeuxjol qui
allait avoir une diminution brutale de
la production industrielle de la
production alimentaire et de la
population
à peu près aux alentours de 2031 après
ça reste un modèle de 1972 bon même si
les mises à jour montré qu'on suivait
parfaitement pour l'instant les
prévisions du business et du jeu
puisqu'on a rien changé fondamentalement
à notre façon d'être au monde à notre
façon de vivre et la façon dont on gère
notre société donc ça c'est un premier
texte fondateur c'est d'ailleurs
l'origine de du petit logo de dadracia
un deuxième texte fondateur c'est tenter
je sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
donc effondrement des sociétés complexes
1988 une analyse super intéressante je
reparlerai un petit peu plus après mais
globalement il y a une loi qui s'appelle
la loi des rendements décroissants et en
fait ce qu'a fait tinder c'est qu'il a
recherché à analyser les effondrements
du passé en appliquant en fait ce modèle
là et pour montrer en fait que pourrait
être les effondrements de société future
et sur plein d'aspects en fait des
analyses qu'il a qu'il a réalisé on est
arrivé aujourd'hui nous notre société
témoin industrielle a un point qui
pourrait en fait conduire à un
effondrement selon ce modèle voilà c'est
deux textes fondateurs d'adracia on
reviendra sur les effondristes et les
effondrements un peu plus tard comment
ça se passe
dans un système contraint quand comment
ça se passe avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique dans un système contraint
dans un système où il y a des événements
exotiques qui les secoue un petit peu on
a vu qu'avec le covid notre état nous
institutions censées nous organiser être
prêt à tout type de menace
ils étaient comme des canards sans tête
à courir partout
a inventé que vendre des masques c'était
10000 euros d'amende pour un pharmacien
comment toi tu as vécu ça c'est
désorganisation comment tu as vécu le
fait de voir des institutions à raconter
tout et son importe quoi un peu tout le
temps y compris jusqu'au plus haute
sphère de l'État et ensuite on va parler
de comment se comporte l'industrie
pharmaceutique et notre état dans un
système contraint de pénurie de guerg
géopolitique de pression géopolitique
sur le qui va fournir quel type de
molécule et en quelle quantité je te
laisse la parole
j'ai envie de finir de répondre à ta
question précédente pour commencer parce
que je t'ai parlé de comment on vit
l'effondrement en 2014 c'était quand
même une période où c'était assez
difficile mais suite à ça il y a plein
de choses qu'on change il y a eu des
événements marquants il y a eu la
démission de Nicolas Hulot par exemple
il y a beaucoup marqué les esprits
il y a eu un vrai
un vrai changement je trouve aux
alentours de l'été 2018 avec notamment
le journal 20 minutes qui a fait une
série sur l'effondrement ce qui était
quand même jamais arrivé dans un journal
grand public en quatre épisodes c'est le
moment où cette notion d'effondrement
elle a commencé à je dirais pas devenir
complètement mainstream mais vraiment à
se poser à se poser comme une
possibilité dans le dans le grand public
donc je pense que le regard a beaucoup
changé sur cette question d'effondrement
il y a de plus en plus de gens qui se
posent des questions par rapport à ça
même si j'en ai encore beaucoup qui me
disent non mais effondrement non moi je
pense que les choses vont se dégrader
lentement et puis que bon bah oui
effectivement la population je suis très
etc
ce qui correspond grosso modo à la
définition de l'effondrement mais mais
je pense que c'est le terme qui pose
problème donc après on peut batailler
entre effondrement déclin et tout ça je
pense que vivre ça aujourd'hui
franchement c'est devenu beaucoup moins
difficile
je en tout cas moi de mon expérience
personnelle je suis passé de d'une
époque tu vois de moi ma prise de
conscience c'était 2015 2015 2016 où on
me regardait un petit peu travers avec
une forme de curiosité
et il y a eu il y a eu une vraie il y a
une phase un petit peu un petit peu
comment dire exploratoire où j'ai pas
mal de gens que ça questionné parce que
parce que c'était moi en fait et qui
sont dit mais elle a pas le profil pour
tomber dans une secte des choses comme
ça et il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
questionnés qui sont questionnés
là-dessus et ce que
qui bossaient sur l'effondrement comme
une secte
non c'était je pense que à l'époque
tu vois ça avait ce petit côté hyper
alarmiste hyper extrémiste quelque part
tu vois dans le dans la projection
principalement par ignorance de ce que
c'était en fait réellement que
l'effondrement d'une société complexe
donc c'était un petit peu ouais un peu
tombé du côté obscur hyperpessimiste et
de plus en plus finalement il y a plein
de gens qui sont mis qui sont mis à
poser plein de questions
mais mais Clémence ça va dans ta vie
c'est pas en train de nous faire une
petite dépression là
ben non en fait après c'est pas trop
c'est pas trop dans mon dans mon
tempérament je vais pas te dire que ça a
été ça a été hyper dur il y a une
période franchement j'ai une période
très difficile tu vois juste après la
prise de conscience
parce que ça active toutes tes peurs en
fait enfin ça remet en question ça remet
en question toute ta conception du monde
tout a conception de l'avenir
moi j'étais un bon petit produit bien
formaté tu vois quand tu vois ce que tu
peux être quand tu sors d'acheter donc
avec avec
une espèce de croyance dans l'infinitude
de beaucoup de choses avec toutes ces
croyances qu'on a par défaut quand on
sait pas intéressé à ces sujets parce
que c'est pas le cas moi je sais pas
pensé par toi même c'est pas en fait
c'est je pense que j'étais capable de
penser sur les sujets sur lesquels je
travaille c'est juste que des trucs
comme l'écologie l'énergie le climat la
biodiversité c'était des trucs auxquels
je m'étais jamais intéressé et quand tu
connais pas des sujets souvent tu as des
tu as des tu as des croyances à la con
des croyances par défaut qui détruisent
du style ah oui c'est pas cool mais il y
a bien un ingénieur quelque part qui va
nous trouver une solution tu vois pour
pour régler mais ouais par exemple
et puis bon bah le jour où tu commences
à creuser sérieusement le truc là tu
commences à réaliser l'ampleur en fait
et la gravité de la profondeur en fait
de cette crise donc moi je suis passé
d'un extrême à l'autre tu vois de
vraiment de d'un extrême de croyance
dans l'abondance etc dans le capitalisme
dans plein de choses et en l'espace de
juste quelques mois parce que je suis
passé du coup par une espèce de phase de
boulimie militaire parce que parce que
quand j'ai commencé à mettre le doigt
dedans quand j'ai commencé à lire à
chaque fois je me disais non mais c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible et
qu'est-ce que je faisais je creusais
plus j'allais chercher un autre bouquin
puis comme quand tu commences à
développer une pensée systémique tu
tires le fil tu passes tu passes du
climat tu vas tu vas sur l'énergie tu
vas sur les ressources minières tu vois
c'était l'époque en plus de la sortie de
l'âge de l'hôtel de Philippe bwix tu
vois c'est tous ces bouquins qui qui qui
m'ont forgé en fait cette pensée là puis
du coup tu vas creuser sur la
biodiversité partout où tu creuses tu
réalises que c'est le bordel que c'est
que c'est gravissime et donc et puis
après tu fais le lien entre tout ça face
les échelles c'est l'échelle de Paul
chez Furka les échelles de conscience
donc moi je suis passé du stade 1 à 5 en
l'espace de quelques mois donc ça a été
quelque chose d'assez d'assez violent
qui a vraiment bouleversé ma vie qui a
activé beaucoup de peur avec forcément
tu vois un réflexe survivaliste là je
pense que c'est assez humain à ce moment
là de te dire
comment faire pour s'en sortir tu es
vraiment dans un réflexe de survie et de
te dire
c'est tous ces gens de ceux qui se
disent ce qu'il faut partir en
Nouvelle-Zélande est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
être en Bretagne que sur la Côte d'Azur
et tout ça tout ça c'est toujours la
même pensée qui est d'essayer de se dire
survivre à tout prix donc j'ai eu une
phase comme ça bon j'ai appris plein de
choses c'était très intéressant et tout
et puis il y a un moment
c'était pas une option pour moi
mais bon il y avait peut-être la
Bretagne tu vois
mais non en fait il y a un moment je
pense
où je suis arrivé au bout de mes peurs
et en fait
j'ai lâché prise et j'ai complètement
changé de mindset et là tu vois j'ai
envie de j'ai envie de d'état d'esprit
pardon ouais j'ai envie de citer Orwell
cette phrase tu sais qui est dans son
livre 1984 qui dit et si au final le
plus important c'est pas de rester
vivant mais c'est juste de rester humain
et je pense que c'est là que là j'ai
changé je me suis dit mais si le monde
doit gérer dégrader de cette façon j'ai
pas envie de survivre là dedans j'ai pas
envie de faire partie des derniers ou
quelque chose comme ça dans un monde de
merde en fait donc je suis vraiment
passée je suis revenue dans le présent
déjà parce que ce qui cause toutes ces
peurs toutes ces angoisses finalement
c'est la projection dans le futur donc
je suis revenue dans le présent et je me
suis dit
en fait la seule chose sur laquelle j'ai
prise c'est ce que je peux faire
maintenant et c'est de me dire et bah
peut-être que ma vie elle sera plus
courte que prévu mais la seule chose qui
compte c'est ce que je vais en faire
de vie réduite parce que moi
d'alimentation ou parce qu'il fait plus
chaud
enfin tout ce qui nous menace je veux
dire ça peut être plein de choses mais
je me suis dit
c'est pas grave en fait c'est pas grave
c'est finalement c'est pas la quantité
qui compte c'est la qualité je suis
vraiment revenu dans le présent en me
disant la vie c'est maintenant et j'ai
envie de faire ce qui me plaît donc une
des premières choses que j'ai faite par
exemple c'était de quitter Paris tu vois
de rentrer chez moi être auprès de
auprès de mes proches de ma famille et
tout ça et de me dire je profite ici et
maintenant et aussi de m'engager dans
des choses qui me paraissaient utile des
choses qui me plaisent comme adresse par
exemple tu vois m'engager dans dans
l'association j'ai pas parlé d'ailleurs
des des missions d'arasia on se fait une
petite parenthèse là dessus et ensuite
on va enchaîner sur le médicament
donc je vous ai dit donc face à ce déni
à dracia je pense qu'ils avaient besoin
de se retrouver aussi parce que c'est
compliqué de rester tout seul quand tu
as pris cette quand tu as pris
conscience de tout ça et que tu as
besoin de te regrouper
je sais pas si c'est une question de
confiance en soi c'est plus une question
à la fois de peur et un sentiment de
décalage avec ton entourage c'est
souvent ça parce que toi tu fais un
chemin énorme en termes de prise de
conscience et la plupart des gens qui
t'entourent ils sont restés au monde
d'avant et ça c'est pas forcément facile
à vivre donc il y a vraiment un besoin
de se rassembler donc les missions que
que c'est posé à dracia la première
c'était d'informer je vous rappelle 2014
il y avait pas beaucoup d'informations
sur sur ce sujet donc c'était avant tout
être vraiment une ressource où on
pouvait trouver de la littérature
scientifique sur le sujet plein de
documentations plein d'analyses donc ça
a été d'abord ça rassemblé toute
l'information pour comprendre en fait
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer comprendre cette convergence des
crises la deuxième mission qu'on s'est
posée
[Musique]
et deuxième mission que qu'on s'était
posé c'est l'accompagnement comme je te
disais vaut mieux pas rester seul et et
prendre soin les uns des autres c'est je
pense que c'est une dimension hyper
importante de la résilience intérieure
et le prix
oui bon anniversaire qui trie
non qui traite on n'est pas encore là et
ben tu vois c'est un bon exemple c'est
ma grande sœur dont c'est l'anniversaire
aujourd'hui et du coup je suis pas en
train de fêter ça avec elle ce soir mais
je suis content d'être avec vous quand
même
non mais c'est un bon point que tu
soulèves tu vois c'est la question de ça
dans la famille typiquement j'en parle
très peu dans la famille parce que parce
que j'ai pas envie de pourrir les repas
de famille parce que parce que ça fait
partie aussi
je pense pas que ce soit des cons et tu
sais et tu sais moi en 2014 j'étais
exactement comme eux donc je vais pas
aller leur jeter la pierre parce que il
y a des événements de la vie qui ont
fait que je suis tombé là-dedans
j'aurais pu ne pas tomber là dedans et
j'en serais au même point que donc je
vais vraiment pas vraiment pas critiquer
non c'est aussi à la fois tu vois je te
disais c'est vachement important de
d'être de vraiment se soutenir tu entre
gens qui qui ont conscience de tout ça
de se regrouper de partager là-dessus et
en même temps et bah c'est sympa aussi
d'avoir des bouffées d'oxygène de temps
en temps et de te dire il y a des
moments où il y a des gens qui sont pas
du tout conscients de tout ça et tu peux
te faire une soirée
avec des gens qui se disent bientôt on
ira tous vivre sur Mars ou des choses
comme ça et moi je me marre un peu dans
mon coin mais finalement c'est pas grave
tu vois ça me fait ça me fait une petite
bulle où je sors un peu de de ces
questions là donc c'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai que j'ai envie de pousser
et d'ailleurs j'ai pas précisé mais une
des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai j'ai
choisi de rejoindre à darrassia donc
adracia c'est une association qui a une
ligne qui est hyper particulière et qui
est vraiment très scientifique donc
c'est c'est un choix c'est un choix qui
vient principalement de Vincent Vignerot
qui est le fondateur de l'association
que tu as reçu bonjour à 17h bonsoir
Vincent qui est passé alors c'était pas
le même fauteuil mais qui est passé qui
est passé avec toi en 2017
donc ça c'est un choix vraiment de
s'attacher à la rigueur scientifique
c'est-à-dire que chez adracia nous on
choisit de croire ce que la science
c'est donc ça déjà c'est quelque chose
qui me plaisait beaucoup en tant que
scientifique et dans je pense que c'est
dans la partie déontologie il y a deux
choses qui m'ont vachement plus quand
j'ai lu ça la première c'est que
c'est qu'on refuse le prosélytisme
c'est c'est notre truc chez darcien
c'est un choix qu'on a fait nous on pose
l'information la met à disposition mais
on va pas aller chercher à faire des
conférences grand public on va pas aller
chercher à surprendre des gens et leur
balancer tout ça parce que on est les
premiers à savoir comment ça peut
bouleverser une vie donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a choisi de ne pas
faire donc on fait pas de prosélytisme
l'info elle est là vous venez la
chercher si vous voulez et l'autre point
c'est qu'il y a une phrase c'est plus
quoi exactement comment est-ce qu'elle
est formulée mais c'est que
l'association
considère et accepte l'idée que elle
sera dissoute si jamais on nous apporte
la preuve que l'effondrement peut être
évité
et ça j'adore en tant que scientifique
moi j'adore parce que c'est hyper
honnête parce que ça laisse cette petite
porte et ça rappelle aussi que ce que la
science c'est elle le sait dans un cadre
donné et à un moment donné et que on
sait jamais comme on dit
pour l'instant si tu veux aujourd'hui
j'ai aucune raison de penser qu'on
puisse éviter l'effondrement je pense
c'est ça c'est un avis personnel je
pense que le processus est déjà bien
engagé qu'on est en plein dedans on s'en
rend pas compte mais qu'on est en plein
dedans il y a que les historiens du
futur qui pourront déterminer si c'est
effectivement le cas si on peut
qualifier ça d'effondrement donc je suis
pas sûr que nous notre vivant on puisse
en avoir la certitude c'est pas bien
grave
biodiversité ça c'est indéniable ouais
alors je parle de l'effondrement
systémique global celui qui qu'on
considère comme inéluctable aujourd'hui
chez adracia mais on le considère
inéluctable parce que aujourd'hui il y a
rien de concret et de vraiment de
convaincant qui nous permet de penser
qu'on pourrait l'éviter et ça ça nous
amène à la troisième mission d'arastia
qui est de promouvoir les initiatives en
fait toutes les initiatives qui
pourraient permettre
d'amortir le choc en fait de faire en
sorte que se déclin il soit le moins
brutal possible et que moi
personnellement aussi cueillez le moins
de souffrance humaine possible en fait
au cours de ce cours de ce processus
voilà pourquoi j'ai choisi de rejoindre
adresse
de Jérémy d'ailleurs pourquoi ces gens
qui sont pourtant documentés
scientifiquement l'intérêt si intéresse
si peu les politiques
et ben je suis pas sûr qu'ils
intéressent peu les politiques comment
tu mesures l'intérêt des politiques
parce que je suis pas sûr que il soit
pas intéressé alors aujourd'hui parce
que depuis 2014 encore une fois on a
fait du chemin
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit pas au
courant
et ça pose deux questions ça pose la
question de est-ce qu'ils ont la volonté
d'agir et est-ce qu'ils ont la
possibilité d'agir
ça il faut leur demander moi je sais pas
je sais pas s'ils sont au courant et qui
sont dans le déni ça s'il faudrait leur
poser la question ce qui est sûr c'est
que aujourd'hui ils font ils font ils
font rien ils font rien pour l'amortir
il faut rien pour pour l'éviter alors
après je suis pas d'accord avec toi
regarde c'est vrai on va tous rouler en
voiture électrique ça va être vachement
bien ouais on aura tais-toi végétalisé
au dessus des des
mars
d'après le lieu de Meuse qui avec mon
implant de rallye ça va bien se passer
on sera tous heureux au baisse devant
Netflix ça va être génial ouais ou pas
trêve de plaisanterie tu bosses dans la
dans la pharmaco on viendra sur un
parascial il faudra voir un peu
on va parler surtout ta perception quand
tu as vu ces organismes courir comme des
canards sans tête pour trouver des
masses du gel hydroalcoolique des
respirateurs quand on a vu des
constructeurs de
de voiture commencer à proposer à faire
des respirateurs ou des choses comme ça
toi ça t'a fait quoi
et ben écoute moi j'ai trouvé ça
magnifique
je savais que ça allait te surprendre
non non mais honnêtement le bilan que je
fais du du covid maintenant on a un
petit peu de recul même si elle est
toujours là un covid il restera avec
nous probablement jusqu'à la fin de
l'humanité mais le bilan de la crise en
fait tu vois la crise la pandémie même
si tout est pas rose
moi ce que j'ai vu c'est que ce soit au
niveau de ce qui nous gouverne au niveau
du personnel soignant j'ai vu une
mobilisation absolument fabuleuse
vraiment je trouve que ils se sont tous
bougés à fond alors
côté politique ok ça a peut-être été un
peu le bordel mais honnêtement tu vois
enfin le meilleur professeur c'est
l'expérience et l'expérience
j'étais réserviste
je la connaissais pas j'en connais
d'autres mais
on a eu vraiment l'impression qu'il y
avait de l'impréparation que au départ
ils ont cherché à minimiser parce qu'il
savait pertinemment que ils étaient pas
capables d'assurer toi tu as pas perçu
ça
mais ça c'est de la com tu vois après
dans dans les faits je suis d'accord
avec toi que ça a été le bazar et tout
mais comme je te dis le meilleur
professeur pour apprendre c'est
l'expérience l'expérience on n'avait pas
on n'a jamais eu une pandémie de cette
ampleur et tout ça donc forcément on
n'allait pas bien faire je trouve
honnêtement qu'on s'en est vachement
bien sorti sachant que on n'avait pas
cette expérience que on fera on fera
mieux la prochaine fois parce qu'on a
appris on a appris beaucoup de choses tu
disais le personnel soignant enfin et je
l'ai vu que ce soit que ce soit à côté
des hôpitaux dans l'armée aussi une
mobilisation qui a été juste
exceptionnelle et de la part de
anticiper il n'y a pas des gens qui
viennent appeler à drastia pour dire
écoutez bon ça fait 30 ans qu'on fait
pas grand chose
on fait des scénarios mais bon on n'a
jamais rien anticipé il faudra peut-être
nous éclairer ils viennent ils viennent
pas vous voir un petit peu pour essayer
de
développeront pas fait ça encore
on serait ravis de leur donner un
éclairage si il le souhaite je suis pas
sûr que je suis pas sûr qu'il soit pas
ou quoi honnêtement je pense que là on
est en 2023 il y a un grand chemin qui a
été parcouru depuis qu'on a porté ce
sujet là tu en 2014 et
le problème il est pas là le problème
c'est c'est l'incapacité à vraiment
faire quelque chose sans un changement
profond et je pense qu'ils sont pas
faits pour un pour un changement profond
mais pour terminer sur le covid donc je
te disais une mobilisation et moi je
l'ai vu de l'intérieur j'ai été
réserviste à l'armée à ce moment là
enfin c'est c'est incroyable comment
comment les gens se sont se sont bougés
comment ils ont donné de leur personne
de leur temps perso ils ont pris des
risques aussi parce que ça faut pas
l'oublier au tout début de la pandémie
on savait rien
enfin quasiment rien on savait quasiment
rien sur sur ce virus on savait
quasiment rien sur ce que ça pouvait
donner on avait encore pas donné on
savait quasiment pas ce que ça pouvait
donner à long terme et tout ça il y a
des gens qui sont allés au charbon quand
même en sachant les risques qui
prenaient et ça je trouve ça vraiment
magnifique je trouve que c'était tu as
suivi un petit peu parce que quand je
t'entends j'ai l'impression bon tu es
profondément gentil et que tu ne juges
pas et que tu refuses de leur mettre des
coups de bâton
moi quand je vois les seuls qu'on gérer
correctement
EDF il doit avoir des sièges de
prospective qui tiennent la route parce
que ils étaient pas pris au dépourvu ils
avaient leur stock de masse qu'ils
avaient un protocole pour leur centrale
nucléaire ils avaient un protocole pour
huiler les gars les autres bon alors
l'armée nous ont montré qu'ils étaient
capables de mettre un hôpital de
campagne sur un parking
d'accord quand même attends le MR de
Mulhouse c'était c'était un sacré truc à
mettre en place et puis c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut staffer en plus c'est à
dire que ça a été la mobilisation
matérielle et humaine qui a été quand
même réalisé dans un temps records
dessus on est d'accord le manque des EPI
et tout ça l'impréparation encore une
fois je la nie pas du tout et je fais
comme je te dis ça nous était jamais
arrivé donc c'était sûr qu'on allait se
planter sur plein de choses c'était sûr
qu'on allait être relativement mauvais
je trouve que globalement on s'en est
plutôt bien sorti en revanche moi il y a
un point sur lequel je serais vraiment
critique ça a été ça a été au niveau de
la communication qui a été faite par
notre gouvernement
je pense que ils sont vraiment passés
ils sont vraiment passés à côté d'une
occasion c'est à dire que
ils ont fait preuve d'un mépris social
que j'ai trouvé assez effarant je pense
en particulier à cette déclaration de
pendant les masques puis c'est pas
facile à mettre c'est pas la portée de
tout le monde sans déconner dire ça dire
ça aux Français à tous les Français qui
bossent dans l'agroalimentaire qui
bossent dans l'industrie pharma dans
plein de métiers dans plein de métiers
les soignants qui sont des gens qui au
quotidien savent ce que c'est que des
EPI savent mettre un masque ils savent
mettre une charlotte etc allez leur dire
aux Français un masque c'est compliqué à
mettre je trouve que là en fait ils ont
vraiment raté une occasion de faire
confiance aux Français ils ont raté une
occasion d'être honnête ils ont surtout
raté une occasion de d'éducation en fait
je pense que vraiment c'est un truc
qu'on a raté sur la crise covid on avait
l'opportunité
de de faire enfin de l'éducation sur sur
la santé sur le médicament c'est c'est
un peu pour ça que je suis là aussi
parce que je pense qu'il y a une vraie
carence de compréhension de de tout ça
de la biologie d'une façon générale et
du médicament en particulier dans la
dans la population française et c'est
une occasion qu'ils auraient pu saisir
et de se dire on va en profiter en plus
les gens étaient confinés et bien ils
étaient un peu à dispo et en profiter
pour faire de l'éducation populaire pour
vraiment apporter de l'info et ça et ça
c'est de la transparence et tout ça ça
génère de la confiance et je pense qu'à
ce moment-là il y a un espèce de il y a
un espèce de gouffre en fait de
confiance qui s'est créé entre le
gouvernement et les Français et qui a
généré plein de problématiques par la
suite parce que les Français avaient pas
confiance donc après oui ça a été le
bazar dans l'organisation tu disais
aussi ça changeait d'avis régulièrement
et tout ça
ça moi en tant que scientifique
franchement ça me rassure
pourquoi parce que enfin la science
c'est évoluer avec les données on
partait de rien et des données il en est
arrivé tous les jours des nouvelles le
scientifique à chaque fois qu'il y a une
nouvelle donnée qui arrive il doit être
capable de se remettre en question et
d'adapter son analyse et son
comportement et donc moi au contraire
quand il changeait d'avis régulièrement
j'étais plutôt rassuré parce qu'il
tenait compte des nouvelles données qui
arrivaient et paradoxalement il y a
plein de français chez qui ça peut
briser la confiance parce qu'il disait
mais s'ils changent d'avis chaque
semaine c'est qu'ils savent pas ce
qu'ils font non c'est parce qu'en fait
on s'est retrouvé dans une crise qui
était complètement inouïe avec en plus
au-delà de là on a parlé de la
mobilisation on a notamment en France
mais ça a été une mobilisation
scientifique sans précédent aussi
vous inquiétez pas vous allez au théâtre
mais je parle de la communauté
scientifique en fait pas encore une fois
pas de nos panneaux politiques
par exemple
tu as eu une explosion de décès clinique
qui ont été mis en place alors sachant
que les essais cliniques c'est des
médecins qui travaillent c'est des
médecins qui étaient déjà débordés de
boulot par le covid mais qui eux savent
que la seule façon qu'on avait de s'en
sortir le mieux possible de cette
pandémie c'était de d'apprendre c'était
de comprendre pour savoir quoi faire et
donc on a eu en fait pléthore de données
qui ont été recueillies partout dans le
monde en France comme ailleurs alors
peut-être de façon pas très très
organisée parce que bon on a fait ça
dans l'urgence mais en tout cas on a une
mobilisation énorme et on a recueilli
dans un temps qui est juste record une
quantité de données qui a été assez
impressionnante et qui nous a permis
d'avancer
quand t'as vu le scandale du Lancet où
il y a eu des choses qui étaient un
petit peu qui ressemblaient le plus à un
ménage qu'autre chose où il poussait
dans un sens plutôt qu'un autre
quand il y a eu des canards
scientifiques qui ont été influencés à
gauche ou à droite tu as suivi c'est un
peu ou pas du tout tu fais référence à
la à l'étude sur la sur la megabase en
Australie non je crois c'était c'était
ça qui a été retiré après
alors ça c'est des choses qui peuvent
arriver je veux dire la science c'est on
va faire un petit point
non je suis pas sûr c'est juste que ça
arrive régulièrement mais tout le monde
s'en fout en fait le enfin public s'y
intéresse pas forcément
la science c'est quoi la science c'est
c'est pas la vérité c'est la recherche
de la vérité c'est la recherche de la
réalité la méthode alors la méthode ce
que c'est la méthode scientifique c'est
t'observes tu as des idées t'aimer une
hypothèse et à partir du moment où tu as
une hypothèse tu vas venir la confronter
au réel tu vas venir la confronter au
fait tu vas la confirmer ou l'infirmer
et c'est comme ça que ça te permet de
progresser la science c'est ce qui nous
permet de comprendre notre monde de
comprendre ce qui se passe en fait et au
fur et à mesure que tu vas additionner
accumuler en fait un certain nombre de
données sur un sujet tu vas finir faire
aboutir à ce qu'on appelle un consensus
scientifique on en a beaucoup on a
beaucoup parlé c'est ce moment où en
fait tu as un
comment dire un grand nombre en fait
d'organismes représentatif que ce soit
au niveau national international qui
arrive à un accord et on considère qu'à
partir de là il y a consensus un
consensus c'est pas uneanimité ça n'est
jamais et en théorie un consensus c'est
pas éternel non plus c'est à dire qu'on
peut avoir un consensus
scientifique et avoir une étude qui
débarque et qui bouscule toutes les
croyances enfin toutes les connaissances
pardon
effectivement ils avaient pas encore la
méthode scientifique vraiment développée
à l'époque mais tout à fait et donc en
fait donc un consensus c'est le moment
où en fait on remet plus les choses en
cause en question tout en gardant
toujours la porte ouverte de se dire
peut-être qu'il y a un truc qui va
vraiment nous surprendre et qui va venir
casser ça maintenant plus un consensus
établit plus la quantité de preuves est
solide moins il y a de chance pour qu'un
jour ils puissent ils puissent être mis
en question
ce qui est important en fait dans la
science c'est c'est le collectif
pourquoi parce que un scientifique
un médecin par exemple un chercheur
c'est juste un être humain avec tous les
travers que ça peut avoir un être humain
ça peut déraper pour plein de questions
pour des questions d'égo pour des
questions d'argent pour des questions de
pouvoir pour plein de choses donc un
être humain ça peut dériver et en fait
le collectif ça c'est le garde-fou
contre la dérive individuelle c'est pour
ça que c'est hyper intéressant de
toujours regarder
la position d'une société savante ou
encore plus fort que ça le consensus
scientifique le consensus scientifique
c'est ce qui nous protège en fait des
dérives individuelles donc un
scientifique indépendant qui qui dit que
lui il va à l'encontre de la pensée
unique etc moi c'est le dernier que je
vais écouter
parce que ça veut dire qui va à
l'encontre de des conclusions auxquelles
sont arrivées tous les autres qui
maîtrisent extrêmement bien le sujet et
des preuves qui ont été qui ont été
accumulées donc ça c'est vraiment
important de garder cette notion de se
dire la science c'est une affaire
collective et c'est le collectif qui
nous permet d'avancer
revenons à l'industrie pharmaceutique
dans un milieu sous contrainte
comment ça se passe des questions qui
sont en train d'arriver pourquoi toutes
les chaînes de production de médicaments
sont privés
pourquoi ne pas faire une chaîne de
production d'État comment éviter que les
politiques soient de formation SUP DE
COM ou de type HEC pour augmenter leur
capacité de compréhension et la
curiosité scientifique
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur l'intérêt
d'avoir une souveraineté sanitaire
prostate il y a combien de médicaments
qui sont en tension il y a combien de
pénurie ça revient tous les combien de
temps
c'est le résultat de de longues années
de de politique et notamment de
politique économique mais pas que donc
je te propose c'est ok on repart de la
base du médicament pour être sûr de quoi
on parle
un vaccin est un médicament un vaccin
par ARN c'est quoi c'est une substance
qui est destinée à être administrée à
l'être humain avisé préventive d'une
maladie humaine avec une action
immunologique ça répond parfaitement la
définition du médicament donc dans le
médicament tu vas avoir tous ceux auquel
tu penses plus les vaccins
éventuellement les produits de contraste
aussi pour ceux qui ont voilà des
scanners de près doux des choses comme
ça les produits de contraste que c'est
qui vous sont administrés c'est assez
avisé diagnostic cette fois-ci mais
c'est aussi c'est aussi des médicaments
alors des médicaments la plupart tu as
des médicaments qui sont chimiques
d'origine chimique ce qu'on appelle donc
ça ça va être en fait des petites
molécules tu vois par exemple le
paracétamol je pourrais te tracer la
formule de la molécule sur sur une
feuille sur une feuille A4 comment c'est
toujours hexagonale
avec une excroissance mais
de dire grosso modo le paracétamol
petite molécule tu dessines ça sur une
feuille et tu as ce qu'on appelle aussi
les médicaments biologiques donc issus
issus des biotechnologies donc là c'est
des énormes molécules c'est à dire que
globalement si tu voulais être à la même
échelle que mon paracétamol et si tu
voulais que je te fasse je sais pas
genre un suivi nous les rétrops
politiques on n'aurait pas la place dans
la pièce donc ça ça donne juste un
niveau d'échelle des petites molécules
comme ça c'est des petites molécules que
tu vas que tu vas pouvoir alors bon il y
a plein de bottes de production mais que
tu vas pouvoir synthétiser chimiquement
avec trois quatre réactions chimiques tu
vas pouvoir la fabriquer les les
protéines enfin les produits biologiques
c'est des molécules qui sont énormes qui
sont extrêmement complexes et donc
comment est-ce qu'on les fabrique on
utilise le vivant d'où le terme de
biotechnologie c'est-à-dire que on va
utiliser des cellules par exemple des
cellules ovariennes de hamster chinois
dans lesquels on va on va mettre dans le
noyau dans le génome une recette la
recette de la molécule que tu veux
produire par exemple les rétropoïétines
humaines donc
on est sur de la cellule ovarienne de M6
en est loin du hamster t'inquiète pas
aucun animal mais tes torturé pour cette
interview donc en fait tu prends le
jeune pour l'instant ouais donc tu
prends le gène tu vois qui code la
protéine qui t'intéresse et tu vas
l'intégrer dans une dans une cellule
vivante et après tu vas faire passer
dans un fermenteur etc et donc tu vas
faire fabriquer à cette cellule la
molécule donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
les produits biologiques donc il y en a
plein aujourd'hui
globalement deux grands types de
produits tu vois les produits chimiques
et puis les produits biologiques qui
sont arrivés qui sont arrivés dans les
années 80
l'insuline par exemple 82 ça a été la
première synthèse beauté biotechnologie
de d'une protéine d'une protéine humaine
qui était l'insuline avant on
l'extrayait de du pancréas de porc donc
voilà en gros deux grands types de
médicaments alors ce médicament comment
il arrive jusqu'à nous patients donc tu
as une phase de recherche tu vas
identifier la molécule qui t'intéresse
parce qu'elle a interagit avec le
récepteur qui t'intéresse et elle génère
là la réaction physiologique qui
t'intéresse à partir du moment où tu
l'as identifié tu vas passer dans une
phase de développement donc tu as deux
développements parallèles tu as le
développement galénique le développement
galénique c'est de se dire cette cette
pour un produit chimique cette poudre ou
un truc comme ça comment tu la
transforme en quelque chose que je peux
administrer à l'être humain
c'est à dire comment tu vas passer de
ton principe actif à un comprimé une
gélule suppositoire un suppositoire
voilà une jolie spécialité française
une crème
oui c'est mieux d'enlever l'emballage
effectivement
donc ça le meilleur son pour le
suppositoire c'est le petit côté ou le
grand côté c'est le petit côté à
l'intérieur tout à fait voilà c'était la
petite minute pratique donc tu vas la
partie développement galénique tu vas
pas partir de ton principe actif et tu
en fais quelque chose qui est
administrable à l'être humain l'autre
partie c'est le développement clinique
donc là en fait tu vas commencer par une
première phase tata molécule tu vas
commencer par ce qu'on appelle le
pré-clinique le pré-clinique c'est que
tu vas tester ta molécule sur un certain
nombre d'espèces animales
et donc tu vas voir
son devenir siècle on est encore alors
il y a il commence à y avoir pas mal de
recherches pour trouver pour trouver des
alternatives mais c'est pas évident
parce que en fait la
complexité de la vie et la complexité
d'un être vivant d'un mammifère en
l'occurrence elle est vraiment
extrêmement importante et
le truc c'est que qu'est-ce que ça va
t'apprendre le prix clinique cette phase
là c'est une phase uniquement de
d'évaluation de sécurité de du produit
et donc en fait tu vas voir ce que ça
provoque chez l'animal tu vas tester des
doses tu vas voir notamment établir ce
qu'on appelle la dose létale 50 c'est à
dire la dose à partir de laquelle tu as
la moitié des animaux qui meurent et
surtout tu vas explorer le devenir de
cette molécule dans l'organisme donc en
fait on va faire on va tout disséquer on
va faire des coupes de tous les tissus
parce que toi tu avais identifié que ta
molécule elle t'intéresser parce que par
exemple elle avait une action sur le
foie tu vois et donc c'est ça qui
t'intéresse et puis tu vas tu vas
commencer à tester et puis tu vas te
rendre compte que ce récepteur qui
t'intéresse finalement il est il existe
aussi dans l'organisme dans plein
d'autres endroits et qui peut provoquer
des réactions que tu avais pas anticipé
et probablement pas voulu c'est ce qu'on
appelle les effets indésirables donc là
tu vas établir donc la toxicité et le
devenir de cette molécule dans
l'organisme une fois que tu as fait
suffisamment d'essais pour être sûr tu
passes à l'humain c'est le début de la
phase de la phase clinique donc la phase
clinique elle commence par quoi elle
commence par la phase une par des tests
sur des individus sains
donc ça
comment alors oui tout à fait pourquoi
parce que alors
est-ce qu'il y a eu des essais cliniques
sauvages dans des pays lointains où il y
a pas de réglementation ou des choses
comme ça c'est déjà arrivé ou pas
peut-être à une époque franchement je
sais pas peut-être à une époque
cette phase là elle est clé parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle le first in human
et c'est vraiment important parce que il
y aura toujours une première tu peux
tester sur autant d'espèces animales que
tu veux avant il y aura toujours une
première fois chez l'homme
le scientifique américain qui était à la
base d'un nouveau traitement pour la
moelle osseuse comme il y avait pas eu
cette phase de test en Russie il a dit
je serai le premier à m'injecter et il a
sauvé des gens parce qu'ils ont pu
mettre ça en route en Russie juste après
Tchernobyl parce que ça a été le premier
à s'injecter il a pris le premier il en
faut plusieurs pour être sûr hein quand
même c'est la Russie on est quand même 8
milliards il y a une certaine
variabilité quand même donc c'est bien
d'en avoir plusieurs mais ça reste un
petit groupe donc ça effectivement sont
des sont des gens qui se portent
volontaire qui sont qui sont rémunérés
pour ça pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
ont rien à gagner si tu veux on part de
volontaires sains donc eux ils sont pas
malades l'objectif c'est uniquement de
d'établir en fait la sécurité de du
médicament mais chez l'humain donc ça ça
nous permet de voir ce que ça donne tout
un tout simplement chez les humains et
de commencer à établir le lien entre
doses et toxicité alors du coup ça me
fait penser qu'il y avait eu un scandale
alors ça remonte il y a il y a pas mal
de il y a pas mal d'années de mémoire
c'était en Angleterre où il y avait un
certain nombre de jeunes hommes qui
étaient qui étaient morts pendant une
pendant une phase une
et enfin honnêtement tout avait été
respecté c'était vraiment pas de bol
c'est à dire que ça peut arriver il
savait ils sont payés parce que
justement ils prennent un risque et
cette molécule qui pourtant avait passé
tous les tests pré-cliniques et tout ça
mais en fait elle avait posé problème et
défaillance multi organiques et ils sont
plusieurs à être décédés donc
malheureusement ça peut arriver mais
faut qu'il y ait une première
informer les gens qui sont
[Musique]
c'est c'est le principe du consentement
libre et éclairé c'est à dire que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment qui
est vraiment contrôlé en amont qui sont
ok qui connaissent les risques qui
prennent ils savent pourquoi ils sont
payés qui sont informés aussi sur la
molécule qu'on va tester sur eux et ils
choisissent ou non de se porter
volontaire mais ça c'est quelque chose
c'est une chose à laquelle on fait très
attention je te parle de nos jours les
portes modernes
en Afrique on pouvait se faire se
permettre tout ce qu'on voulait c'est ça
non j'allais plutôt te dire que au XIXe
siècle quand on a commencé à faire des
tests des tout premiers vaccins ou des
choses comme ça on était peut-être pas
aussi en regardant mais c'était une
autre époque donc à l'issue de cette
phase 1 tu vas passer à la phase 2 la
phase 2 c'est la première phase où tu
vas commencer à avoir entendu parler de
décès un peu sauvage en Afrique moi
[Musique]
à qui on aura on l'aura pas dit ce que
c'était on aura pas dit les
répercussions moi j'ai plutôt souvenir
j'avais j'avais vu un film qui était
tiré du livre de John Le Carré qui était
ah mince comment il s'appelle
la conscience du jardinier
c'est ça je pense et effectivement mais
c'était enfin moi ça m'avait laissé un
petit peu écœuré parce que la théorie en
fait de du livre c'était que pour
développer en fait un médicament sur une
art-thérapeute je me rappelle plus du
tout il y avait deux labos qui étaient
en concurrence et qu'en gros il y en
avait un qui était allé faire des tests
en Afrique et il y avait des patients
qui étaient morts et ils avaient caché
les morts pour pouvoir être les premiers
à lancer parce que quand tes premiers
c'est là que tu gagnes le plus ce qui
est un non-sens ça montre une
méconnaissance complète en fait du
fonctionnement de ce système parce que
le premier marché que tu vas rechercher
c'est les États-Unis
quel est l'intérêt pour un labo
de lancer aux États-Unis un produit si
il sait que il a il a causé des morts
ça n'a pas de sens un mort américain sur
un produit comme ça ça va te coûter des
milliards donc bref mais bon est-ce que
les labos sont déjà fait condamnés oui
il y a eu des condamnations
je me souviens plus du tout alors là
c'est pas un truc que j'ai creusé je
suis désolé de te dire ça mais il y a eu
quelques affaires
je peux pas te dire en détail ce que
c'était mais il y en avait
tout va bien il y a beaucoup de monde
pas trop d'effets secondaires la phase 2
la phase 2 tu arrives chez le patient
malade c'est-à-dire le patient qui a
quelque chose à gagner donc tu es sur un
petit effectif de patients chez qui donc
on va administrer le médicament et c'est
la phase c'est la phase qui va te
permettre de commencer à évaluer
l'efficacité pour l'instant elle était
que sur des notions de sécurité donc
l'efficacité du médicament sur la
maladie que tu cherches à investiguer et
aussi d'ajuster la dose et après tu
arrives à la phase 3 la phase 3 c'est la
plus large c'est la dernière avant
l'autorisation et donc là tu vas tu vas
tester le produit sur une large partie
en fait une large nombre de patients qui
souffrent de cette maladie
alors là mais c'est complètement
variable en fait c'est tout dépend de la
pathologie du cible
un covid 19 je me souviens plus combien
il y avait dans la phase 3 de Pfizer tu
me poses une colle mais c'est facile à
retrouver ça
mais par exemple tu vas si tu vas être
sur un produit tu as un produit
cardiovasculaire ou un truc comme ça
c'est plusieurs milliers de patients que
inclus dans les dans les phases froid
parce que parce que tu en as parce que
tu as un paquet de patience cible si tu
commences à citer sur une pathologie qui
est relativement rare tu vas forcément
avoir un effectif qui va être plus
restreint c'est pas tant c'est pas tant
une question d'argent c'est une question
de capacité de test aussi parce que un
des grands enjeux que tu as quand tu
quand tu mets en place un essai clinique
c'est donc tu sais que ça se fait c'est
les médecins qui le font installer
laboratoires les laboratoires ils
élaborent les protocoles avec les
médecins mais les patients ils sont à
l'hôpital avec les médecins et donc en
fait ça va être le recrutement le
recrutement des le recrutement des
patients c'est souvent ça le gros
challenge c'est d'arriver à avoir
suffisamment de patients pour remplir
ton objectif statistique qui te
permettra de
d'évaluer les efficacité ou non et donc
on arrive à cette phase 3 quand tu
boucles la phase 3 au bout tu as
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
donc ça c'est le moment où le produit
est enfin autorisé et dans pas mal de
pays du monde en particulier du moment
où tu as l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché le produit est lancé dans le cas
de la France tu vas avoir de nouvelles
étapes en France entre le moment où un
produit obtient son autorisation de
mission de marché européenne et le
moment où il est mis à disposition
concrètement pour les patients français
il se passe environ 16 mois parce que tu
rentres dans une phase de négociation
c'est à dire que ce produit il va être
évalué au niveau de nos agences
par d'abord la commission de
transparence ça c'est la Commission qui
va évaluer ce qu'on appelle le service
médical rendu c'est à dire en gros le
produit est-ce qui est-ce qui
s'intéresse à une maladie importante qui
présente un risque important et est-ce
qu'il apporte un bénéfice important donc
ça c'est ça va définir le ce qu'on
appelle le SMR ça ça va déterminer quoi
ça va déterminer l'intérêt pour la
collectivité de le prendre en charge ce
médicament c'est l'étape du
remboursement
et après tu as une deuxième étape
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle la SMR
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
ça c'est la partie relative c'est de se
dire ok ce médicament il traite une
pathologie qui est grave qui est
importante et il apporte des résultats
satisfaisants cette phase là c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il apporte de plus par
rapport à ce qu'il y avait déjà et ce
qui avait avant donc tu as une note SMS
ce petit dossier d'évaluation ensuite il
part vers ce qu'on appelle le comité
économique des produits de santé donc
c'est l'organe en France qui va donner
son prix aux médicaments puisqu'en
France c'est pas l'industriel qui fixe
le prix de son produit c'est le
Communauté économique des produits de
santé qui va lui donner un prix
je sais pas si tu veux que j'aille plus
loin sur l'évaluation du prix ou pas
encore l'évaluation du prix ça se fait
en toute transparence
en toute transparence alors la
commission de transparence c'était juste
avant sur l'évaluation l'évaluation du
prix alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
de savoir sur quoi elle repose pas
vraiment tout ça ça nous permettra de
comprendre après les pénuries et tout
le prix qui attribué un médicament il
est absolument pas lié à ses coûts de
production il est absolument palier à
ses coûts de développement parce que
aujourd'hui je l'ai pas précisé mais
toutes ces phases que je vous ai
décrites là tout se développant du
médicament aujourd'hui alors plusieurs
études qui sont sorties mais c'est de
l'ordre de entre 800 millions et 1
milliard 6 de dollars d'investissement
c'est ça qui coûte hyper cher en fait
dans le développement d'un médicament en
fonction des types de médicaments et des
pathologies concrètes ça ça varie un
petit peu mais le coup il est là et bah
ça c'est pas pris en compte aujourd'hui
l'évaluation et le prix en fait d'un
médicament il va se baser
sur en fait les économies que ce
médicament va permettre de faire au
système de soins c'est à dire tu traites
ça si patient il est pas traité
concrètement il y en a pour tant de
soins et ça économie ça et en fait on va
partir de cette base pour valoriser
avec un prix déterminé et qui servait en
fait à rien
alors il y a
alors oui c'est ça en fait la notion de
rien je suis pas forcément d'accord
médicament qui sert à rien c'est c'est
très c'est un petit peu absolu tu as des
médicaments qui servent plus ou moins il
y a une époque où en fait il y avait
beaucoup plus de médicaments
qu'aujourd'hui qui était pris en charge
il y a beaucoup de médicaments qui ont
été des remboursés et c'était et c'était
des
plans
tu sais c'est la glande anale de furet
dilué par 25 millions de particules et
ensuite et puis ça fait des petites
bibies
en partant de la glande analyse furet OK
oui alors c'est un cas particulier un
homéopathie parce que le principe le
principe de l'homéopathie c'est la
quantité infinitésimale c'est-à-dire que
alors déjà homéopathie versus allopathie
le principe de l'homéopathie c'est de
penser que en administrant dans une
quantité infime ce qui provoque le mal
permet de traiter le mal tu vois par
exemple
apismel c'est c'est ce que tu vas
prendre en cas de piqûre d'abeille c'est
à dire et c'est du de l'extrait de venir
d'abeille mais ultra dilué puisque les
fameux ch c'est des centaines admienne
donc anneman qui a inventé l'homéopathie
et donc en fait c'est en tu mets une
microquantité et tu es tu rinces 100
fois donc l'idée c'est qu'il en reste
une quantité qui est infinitésimale
c'est quasi nul et après tu mets ça dans
les petites granules effectivement
l'homéopathie c'est vraiment un cap un
cas très particulier parce que
c'est bon c'était remboursé depuis hyper
longtemps depuis à une à une époque à
une époque où on n'avait pas du tout les
mêmes niveaux d'évaluation des
médicaments moi je te parle de ce qu'on
est ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
ça a pas toujours été le cas et donc
l'homéopathie en plus elle a une
particularité c'est qu'elle doit être
vraiment personnaliser pour le patient
et pour le cas du patient c'est-à-dire
que d'une façon théorique l'homéopathie
elle est pas protocolisable et
aujourd'hui
l'évaluation d'un médicament je suis pas
rentrée dans le détail des phases et
tout mais toi quand tu évalues un
médicament tu l'évalues dans un cadre
qui est hyper particulier c'est-à-dire
pour une pathologie donnée avec une dose
donnée une durée traitement donnée et
chez un patient donné c'est un cadre qui
est hyper précis ça va être le cas de
ton autorisation et le problème c'est
qu'il faut que ce soit standard ça et
l'homéopathie elle est pas standard donc
elle est très difficilement
protocolisable donc on a dû voilà même
si on voulait ce serait très compliqué
de de démontrer en fait son efficacité
après le petit bémol que je mettrai donc
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est un truc
qui était pas évalué comme ça pourrait
être aujourd'hui le petit bémol que je
mettrais c'est que franchement ça coût
que dalle
c'était je sais plus un euro 50 le tube
ou 2 euros quelque chose comme ça et ça
faisait permettait potentiellement de
faire je pense des économies donc je
sais pas s'il y a des études qui sont
sortis aujourd'hui sur le report
potentiel depuis
des conflits
d'intérêts c'est-à-dire bossez pour un
labo pendant la peau vous avez des
actions
pour des labos j'ai aucune action ni
quoi que ce soit non mais en fait moi je
travaille pour une association qui
travaille avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques moi j'accompagne en fait
la filière et en l'occurrence moi je
m'occupe de la partie transition
environnementale dans le cluster dans
lequel je travaille c'est à dire que moi
mon quotidien avec les labos c'est
travailler avec les responsables RSE et
responsables techniques surtout ce qui
est sobriété énergétique gestion de
l'eau et préservation de la biodiversité
voilà c'est ça mon quotidien avec
l'élaborateurs donc je les connais bien
je travaille avec eux mais j'ai pas de
enfin je pense pas avoir de lien
en tout cas j'ai pas de conflit
d'intérêt au sens intérêt personnel
voilà
ah tu m'as coupé je me souviens plus où
j'en étais et j'en profite pour caler un
commentaire et te relancer sur une
question j'avais un truc intéressant à
dire mais du coup je l'ai perdu
à plusieurs reprises Sky salut le
travail des producteurs d'électricité de
manière exclusive alors pas que exclusif
parce qu'il y en a d'autres qui ont
bossait mais nous pendant le covid on a
été informé de l'intérieur de ce qui se
passait chez nos producteurs d'énergie
et on a été
on va dire heureux de les voir bien
organisé par rapport aux autres et
donc c'est pour ça chaque fois ça me
revient parce que on a pu juger quelques
quelques industries en question à gauche
et à droite et chez EDF on tient à dire
on a été impressionné bon passons ouais
mais tant mieux franchement je pense que
le covid le covid enfin humainement je
trouve que ça a été très beau cette
mobilisation générale qui a eu et puis
c'était une claque qui était salutaire à
plein d'autres aspects notamment pour la
santé
je suis désolé j'étais coupé avec les
histoires de gauche et comment ça se
fait qu'on s'est retrouvé avec des
tensions sur X medicament qu'on avait
plus de doliprane qu'on avait plus de
machin il y a beaucoup de choses le
profit pourquoi on fait maintenant nos
médicaments en Chine et en Inde plein de
raisons donc c'est pour ça que je vais
reprendre donc
on était arrivé au médicament le
médicament une fois qu'il a son prix il
arrive jusqu'à nous en fait à partir de
là tu vas avoir le médicament il est
protégé alors je le sache pas très
simple mais il est globalement protégé
par un brevet en général sur le sur la
molécule du principe actif et ce qu'on
appelle la protection des données
cliniques globalement un médicament il
est protégé pendant environ 10 ans
parfois un petit peu plus mais pas
beaucoup plus
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un médicament
innovant d'accord il vient de sortir il
est protégé le laboratoire et le seul à
pouvoir le commercialiser à partir du
moment où la protection de ce brevet ou
des données cliniques tombent là tu te
retrouves avec un médicament qui peut
être produit par quelqu'un d'autre
d'accord
donc ça ça a été l'émergence alors pour
les produits chimiques de ce qu'on
appelle les génériques
les génériques alors il y en a eu au
tout début ça a commencé dans les années
80-90 je crois à peu près au début ils
avaient pas de succès parce que
finalement en fait ils étaient tout
aussi chers que que les que les
quasiment aussi cher que les produits
originaux tout simplement parce qu'ils
devaient se taper tout le développement
clinique que je vous ai précisé juste
avant et avec le coup que ça représente
et puis un jour on a on a mis en place
la notion de bio-équivalence la bio
équivalence c'est quoi
c'est c'est en partant d'une notion de
déterminisme biologique et de se dire
que les mêmes causes produisent les
mêmes fait et c'est l'idée de se dire si
on a une équivalence qualitative et
quantitative donc même principe actif
dans la même quantité et avec une étude
de bio-équivalence qui va montrer en
fait que le devenir la cinétique si tu
veux de la molécule dans le corps humain
va être similaire aux produits de
référence et ben on va pas avoir à
refaire tout le dossier qui coûte si
cher de développement clinique
c'est-à-dire qu'on va pouvoir faire
référence au dossier clinique du
médicament d'origine on fait juste cette
étude de bio équivalence on démonte que
c'est bien dans la fourchette et c'est
ce qu'on appelle un médicament générique
et c'est pour ça qu'un médicament
générique aujourd'hui il peut être
beaucoup moins cher
voilà c'est un peu plus compliqué sur
les biologiques on a une notion bios
similaire qui sont pas exactement les
mêmes donc ils sont pas substituables
comme comme peuvent être les génériques
aujourd'hui donc on a on a voilà
certains membres de statues de
médicaments médicament innovants
médicament génériques médicament
biosimilaire
donc à partir de là qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé donc ça tu vois les génériques qui
sont arrivés
ils sont arrivés c'était l'objet de ma
thèse qui sont arrivés vraiment au début
des années 2000 quand il y a eu ces
notions bio équivalence quand il y a eu
surtout 99 le droit de substitution du
pharmacien ça ça a tout changé c'est à
dire que le pharmacien quand tu avais
prescription de du médicament de
référence il avait la possibilité de
donner une boîte de générique à la place
donc ça ça a fait chuter du jour au
lendemain si tu veux ton médicament de
référence les les génériques arrivés et
ton marché ils plongait directement donc
tu as vraiment vraiment un transfert
qui se fait et donc on se retrouve avec
un modèle économique qui est très
différent pourquoi parce que ça c'est
des médicaments déjà le fameux comité
économique des produits de santé dont je
vous ai parlé quand un générique arrivé
ça c'est moins 60 aujourd'hui mais il
arrivait il prenait moins 50 de prix
prix du médicament de référence
qui en plus tout au cours de sa vie
avait baissé je suis pas rentré dans les
dans les dans les détails contractuels
de du prix du médicament mais quand un
labo négocie avec le comité son prix il
négocie son prix il négocie des remises
et il négocie des baisses de prix
régulière je peux je peux poser une
question
qui a fait des SMS à gauche à droite
c'est pas transparent
sur le prix les quantités tout ce que tu
me racontes toi ton avis de
professionnel quand tu vois je me
rappelle pas si c'est quoi le contenu
qui a échangé des SMS avec un grand labo
et le patron d'un grand labo c'est pas
transparent on n'a pas le détail des
contrats qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire ça pose problème pas de
problème alors
Ursula avant dernier et le niveau
européen moi tout ce que tout ce dont
j'étais en train de vous parler c'est le
modèle économique du médicament en
France nos spécificités françaises après
en termes de en termes de transparence
je sais pas ce qu'elle attend qu'est-ce
qu'elle attend en latin un prix de
revient industriel mais aujourd'hui les
prix ils sont pas basés sur les coûts de
production
je ne sais pas
[Rires]
je pense pas que ce soit son rôle mais
après il y a aussi une autre une autre
question qui je pense peut-être que ça
il y a un mélange avec ça là où il y a
un vrai problème de transparence et on
s'en rend compte maintenant parce qu'on
commence à mettre des dents c'était sur
la provenance des médicaments
dire que aujourd'hui toi et moi citoyen
tu as une boîte de médicaments tu sais
pas d'où vient le profil le principe
actif et tu sais pas où il a été formulé
où il était produit
bon c'est en train de changer on pousse
à fond pour ça
il commence à y avoir de grosses
demandes et tout ça alors est-ce que ça
ira jusqu'au citoyens je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas pour déjà avoir un
dossier de transparence maintenant les
autorités de santé en tout cas le
demande elle commence elle le demande
parce qu'elle commence à s'y intéresser
alors qu'avant c'était pas du tout un
critère mais oui mais ça fait partie des
des
comment dire des résultats positifs de
cette grosse claque du covid et alors on
part de loin parce que parce que c'était
des choses qui avant les intéresser pas
mais donc faut revenir j'en étais resté
à notre générique tu vois notre
générique qui débarque au début des
années 2000 qui vient bouleverser le
modèle économique du médicament et là on
est parti dans une politique très
particulière qui a été de se dire en
fait les génériques on va baisser leur
prix régulièrement pour venir financer
l'innovation c'est à dire qu'on est
parti sur une politique alors que ça
s'appelle London en France c'est
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie donc ça c'est nos
députés des votes députés qui votent qui
votent une enveloppe et qui chaque année
demandé des réductions en fait de prise
sur les médicaments que le comité
économique de produits de santé devait
ensuite répercuter et c'est toujours
comment ça autour d'une table avec les
copains
le CEPS aujourd'hui et donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait chaque année ils récupérez
l'ONDAM et on le disait bon cette année
il faut que tu fasses 700 millions par
exemple de d'économies sur sur le
médicament sachant qu'en parallèle en
plus on veut tout en France on s'est pas
posé de limite c'est à dire qu'on veut
toutes les nouveautés donc on voulait à
la fois
accéder aux soins accéder à toutes les
innovations on voulait aussi contraindre
le budget et donc lui qu'est-ce qu'il
avait appliqué c'est à dire savoir où
rogner donc chaque année bah en fait il
regardait son portefeuille il disait bon
sur quelle classe thérapeutique est-ce
que j'ai pas tapé récemment et puis il
disait allez hop cette last
thérapeutique on va leur recoller moins
10 par exemple et ça fonctionnait comme
ça chaque année donc je sais pas si on
peut parler vraiment de négociation même
s'il y en avait certains qui pouvaient
éventuellement dire non mais c'est bon
non nous a tapé dessus l'année dernière
à tapé sur quelqu'un d'autre mais
globalement c'est comme ça que ça se
passait c'est-à-dire que on a en fait
financé notre accès à l'innovation
en réduisant et en serrant séance séance
et en serrant les prix sur quoi sur les
médicaments génériques
je vous ferai un petit point sur
l'histoire du médicament pour voir que
c'est les médicaments les plus
essentiels aujourd'hui et donc ça
qu'est-ce que ça a fait ça a fait toute
une filière sur laquelle on a mis la
pression quand on met la pression
financière sur une filière elle fait
quoi elle optimise donc ça a commencé
par des délocalisations donc
ça réduit bien le je pense la charge
salariale surtout surtout au début des
années 2000 donc ça a été quoi ça a été
délocalisation à commencer par les
principes actifs qu'on refasse un petit
point là-dessus aussi sur les différents
métiers différents types d'entreprises
qui a dans tout ce qu'on met dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais donc
délocalisation
optimisation des process c'est à dire
que tu te retrouves avec des usines qui
ont de moins en moins de marge
un laboratoire qui a un produit innovant
aujourd'hui il peut se permettre d'avoir
une usine qui qui tourne pas à 100% il
sait qu'il a un peu de marge ce qui a
une demande qui augmente il va pouvoir
augmenter un petit peu sa production
on a eu le cas d'un labo américain je
sais plus quand c'était qui s'est pris
un ouragan sur sur son usine aux
États-Unis bah comme c'est un produit
innovant qui fait quand même une bonne
marge et tout ça et ben il avait un site
backup qui peut se permettre un site
backup pas les génériques donc il avait
une ligne qui était prête qui était
validée autorisée et tout ça et qu'après
le relais de la production donc ça voilà
ça tu voilà on commence à voir un petit
peu pourquoi des pénuries donc
globalement tu mets une pression énorme
sur des structures industrielles qui du
coup aura une surtout qui qui se qui
s'approvisionne en principe actif moins
cher donc ils vont les chercher en Chine
en Inde qui qui aussi ont des lignes de
production qui sont de plus en plus
tendues de moins en moins de et de moins
en moins de backup donc on a vraiment
fragilisé finalement cette
cette structure de production de ces
médicaments
après autre facteur puisque là du coup
on commence à rentrer un petit peu dans
le facteur de ce qui provoque les
pénuries
c'est une question de demande
c'est à dire que récemment en fait on a
eu une forte augmentation le la demande
en fait de médicaments mondial c'est si
ça dit pour cent à peu près
d'augmentation chaque année quand tu as
des pays comme l'Inde la Chine qui
commence à avoir les pauvres qui
accèdent à qui deviennent des classes
moyennes qui accèdent aux soins ça fait
une explosion de la demande et cette
demande elle va beaucoup plus vite que
notre capacité à augmenter les capacités
de production parce qu'on parle d'une
filière industrielle avec toute
l'inertie que ça que ça peut représenter
une filière industrielle en général et
en particulier pharmaceutique parce
qu'en plus la filière pharmaceutique
elle est extrêmement normée mais à un
niveau qui est qui est difficilement
concevable vraiment en termes de en
termes de contrôle et tout ça et avec un
niveau croissant c'est à dire qu'on
augmente on continue de de restreindre
de d'affiner les normes et de poser plus
de contraintes et ça c'est un autre
facteur en fait de pénurie c'est que de
plus
ce type de vocabulaire parce que c'est
pas des contraintes c'est renforcé
endurci tu comprends la sémantique ou
pas je vois ce que tu veux dire moi je
présente ça un peu comme contrainte
parce que je pense que il y a des
aspects sur lesquels on avait déjà
atteint un niveau de sécurité qui me
paraissait suffisant après c'est
toujours la question de qui voilà qui
paraissait quand même vraiment suffisant
et on continue d'aller encore plus loin
si tu veux on est vraiment tu sais dans
le la petite marge supplémentaire
ceinture et bretelle pour pour arriver
pour arriver au maximum et ça en fait au
delà du fait que c'est des coûts c'est
des coûts supplémentaires c'est c'est de
la flexibilité en moi
et il y a eu il y a des cas de pénuries
je suis en train de me dire tu essaies
de te trouver un exemple
récent qui a été le cas il y a eu là
c'était un cadeau en plus il y a eu une
pénurie là sur la fin 2022 au début 2023
sur ce qu'on appelle le misoprostol qui
est qui est un des deux médicaments qui
sont utilisés pour l'IVG médicamenteuse
on dit des tensions sur la filière il a
dit le ministre
entre les entre les deux tension c'est
globalement quand approvisionne pas
assez tu vas avoir un contingentement et
tout ça pénurie c'est qui ont pendant un
certain temps un temps donné en fait tu
peux pas approvisionner enfin la
définition c'est quand une pharmacie
elle demande un médicament et que dans
les 72 heures elle peut pas l'obtenir
et donc ce qui s'est passé donc là c'est
un laboratoire en fait qui qui
exploite ces deux produits
parce qu'il y a deux produits en fait
pour le pour la même la même molécule
c'est de ligne de production et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que tu as le premier
produit ou en fait il y avait eu une
erreur de commande
chose qui arrive l'humain est-ce qu'il
est donc il y a une chaîne il y a une
chaîne qui est une chaîne qui est en
Espagne il y a une chaîne qui est en qui
est en France et donc l'usine espagnole
donc les deux s'approvisionnent auprès
d'un chimiste anglais en fait ce qui
produit le principe actif et donc en
Espagne il y a juste quelqu'un ça peut
arriver qui s'est planté dans la
commande de principe actif c'est
peut-être planté de virgule je ne sais
pas on n'a pas les détails toujours
est-il que du coup ils se sont retrouvés
avec une production bientôt pince bien
trop insuffisante
sur la personne qui s'était plantée je
sais pas ça
faisait partie de mouvement radicaux ou
des choses comme ça je ne sais pas il
faut demander au faut demander au labo
nordique c'était c'était en Espagne en
plus donc
je ne sais pas du tout je ne sais pas du
tout s'il y a une enquête je sais pas
c'est un être humain quoi j'ai envie de
te dire on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
erreur et c'est ce qui s'est produit et
donc du coup tu as du coup production
pas du tout assez importante de ce
produit donc ça ça a généré une première
pénurie qui au début a pu être compensé
par le fait que tu avais une deuxième
ligne puisque tu avais une deux
médicaments qui sont deux lignes
différentes et c'est en l'occurrence
c'est une CDMO française
d'elle femme qui fabrique ce deuxième
produit qui du coup a pris le a pris le
relais pour compenser pendant un moment
les le défaut en fait de quantité et là
c'est l'usine française qui a eu un
problème de qualité
et parfois les problèmes de qualité
alors je connais pas les détails de ce
problème de qualité mais il y a des fois
où tu vas trouver quand tu fais tous tes
contrôles analytiques avant de libérer
télo bah tu peux trouver une impureté ou
juste quelque chose qui diffère en fait
quand tu as un cahier des charges qui
est extrêmement strict tu peux avoir une
toute petite différence mais du coup tu
es obligé de mener une enquête et
pendant que tu mènes l'enquête telo ils
sont pas libérés ils restent dans
l'usine donc bien sûr c'est normal donc
exactement et donc ça c'est pour te
montrer un concours de circonstances tu
vois c'était c'était
voilà encore une décidément donc c'était
c'était un coup de pas de bol et puis
derrière ben ça arrive souvent une
investigation qualité où on garde le lot
parce qu'on attend d'être sûr que c'est
pas problématique la petite variation
qu'on a qu'on a repéré et donc ça ça a
généré des tensions enfin une période de
pénurie et puis des tensions des
contingentements pendant une certaine
période c'est un exemple de oui question
d'internet
en 2020 le gouvernement a annoncé
financé six projets de relocalisation de
la production pharmaceutique deux points
montant total 78 millions d'euros ces
projets devaient couvrir diverses
stratégies thérapeutiques vaccinales
antiviral etc
approche technologique chimique
biotechnologie etc savez-vous si ça a
donné du concret alors je sais que c'est
en cours j'imagine qu'il fait référence
à France relance
parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs plans alors
autre autre point super positif du covid
c'est cette claque magnifique
qui a pris qui ont pris nos gouvernants
parce que là on est en train de parler
de pénurie ensemble mais il faut savoir
que les pénuries ça fait très longtemps
que ça dure
mais ça fait très longtemps qu'on les
voit pas
c'est juste qu'on faisait rien moi
au niveau au niveau gouvernemental on
changeait pas on changeait pas les
modalités en fait ce qui s'est juste
anecdote moi quand j'ai commencé à
travailler en 2004 je me rappelle je me
rappelle j'étais jeune consultante d'un
rapport de l'Académie de médecine que
j'ai réussi à retrouver d'ailleurs et
qui disait attention c'est le début des
génériques attention si on ne fait pas
de la santé quelque chose de vraiment
stratégique et si on protège pas
notamment le médicament ça va nous
échapper tout va être délocalisé on va
perdre la main là-dessus et
on va avoir des pénuries voilà trouver
2004 on a commencé à vraiment avoir
cette inquiétude là ça a commencé à se
manifester en fait c'est prédiction
finalement parce que ça s'est passé
comme prévu il y a eu plein de
délocations il y a eu plein
délocalisations et tout à partir de 2010
à commencer à se voir un petit peu en
2014 2016 sur cette période là
des des pénuries on avait entre 400 et
pour donner une petite idée c'était
c'était déjà embêtant mais c'était pas
encore très très grave
2018 on était passé à plutôt 7800 savait
quasiment doublé et là ça commence à
devenir un pénurie je me dis toujours ça
touche combien de personnes parce que si
c'est sur une maladie cardiovasculaire
si c'est sur une crème hémorroïdaire ou
si c'est sur un traitement de
chimiothérapie c'est possible de savoir
est-ce que ça va être géré c'est à dire
que ta pénurie est-ce que ça est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça a fait est-ce que ton
pas déjà faut savoir c'était pourquoi
pour tel type de pathologie tel gravité
et tu sais pas ce qui s'est passé
derrière est-ce que cette pénurie ça a
créé un retard de traitement ou est-ce
que ça a créé un report de traitement
est-ce que du coup on a donné autre
chose aux patient donc c'est compliqué
il faut il aurait fallu faire des études
spécifiques là dessus pour savoir
qu'elle avait été le devenir si tu veux
d'une ordonnance qui était pas honorée à
l'instant T donc ça c'est ça c'est très
difficile de savoir c'est très difficile
de l'évaluer de production elle se
calibres
25 caisses de 25000 gélules si j'ai pas
le marché qui va déboucher derrière donc
l'industriel derrière il a une
anticipation son marché non comment ça
se gérer complètement alors si sur son
anticipation de marché sur ces 3000
références et 600 références ce que tu
ce que tu veux
avec une pathologie moyenne pour 75 kg
pour par personne
tu m'as compris
cette question c'est aussi un facteur de
pénible le point que tu soulève là c'est
la difficulté d'anticipation quand tu es
industrielle tu dois vachement anticiper
tu dois anticiper pour ton
approvisionnement en matière première
notamment en API tu vas anticiper pour
ton planning de production parce que tu
peux tu peux avoir t'as pas toujours une
ligne qui est destinée à plein temps
tout le temps pour le même médicament tu
vas avoir des stratégies d'État est-ce
que
terminer juste parce que tu vois ces
lignes tu vas devoir faire un planning
de prod sur ton site de production tu
vas avoir plusieurs lignes tu vas avoir
la capacité par exemple tu es un site
qui est qui est spécialisé sur les
formes sèches je fais du comprimé la
gélule tu vas faire un certain nombre de
spécialités tu vas avoir un planning de
produits qu'il faut que tu puisses
anticiper et déjà anticiper c'est pas
facile et est-ce que tu viens de
soulever ce point là c'est par exemple
la cause majeure de la pénurie qui a eu
de paracétamol et d'amoxicilline c'est
parce qu'il y a eu un choc de demande
qui était pas près
donc c'est pas facile d'accord mais je
me pose une question c'est peut-être pas
les bons au bons postes
les bonnes personnes s'ils arrivent pas
anticiper
franchement je pense qu'ils sont très
expérimentés et tout c'est juste que tu
peux pas être devant tu peux pas devenir
tu peux pas tu peux pas deviner tu
pouvais pas savoir veille sur ce qui
traîne comme ça
il y a de la veille qu'il y aura pas des
choses qu'on voit pas venir et la triple
la triple épidémie qu'on a eu cet hiver
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas vu
venir donc aujourd'hui si tu veux les
les
industries tu voulais savoir les trois
est-ce que c'était c'était
le RSV en fait ce qui provoque la
bronchiolite le covid et la grippe
voilà donc qui en même temps triple
épidémie dans un temps court en plus
donc avec toutes les contraintes
logistiques que ça implique ça personne
ne pouvait le prévoir et donc en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y a eu ce
qu'on appelle un choc de demande donc
c'est pas que les usines elles tournent
pas c'est pas que les industriels ils
avaient pas ce qu'il fallait c'est juste
que à un moment donné et dans un temps
très court il y a eu une explosion de la
demande et ils ont pas et ils ont oui je
sais puis en plus ils ont parlé de plein
de choses ils ont dit que ça venait du
principe actif qui venait de Chine alors
que c'est pas le cas enfin bref non en
fait je simplifie un peu le truc il y
avait il y avait des tensions
d'approvisionnement qui mais ces temps
sont approvisionnement ce qu'elles ont
fait c'est qu'elles ont limité la
capacité d'adaptation de nos acteurs en
gros si tu prends l'exemple du
paracétamol ces deux acteurs en France
c'est de laboratoire il y en a un il a
doublé sa capacité de production pour
essayer de faire face à ce choc de
demande alors c'est le fournisseur qui
est minoritaire mais dans voisinage ils
se sont ils se sont mieux passés aux
trois bits ils ont travaillé jour nuit
et week-end pour essayer d'augmenter au
maximum leurs production sur un autre un
autre site à Lisieux eux ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont pu ils ont essayé d'augmenter
mais ils avaient des difficultés
d'approvisionnement parce que
l'industrie pharma elle a pas seulement
besoin de principe elle a besoin
d'aluminium elle a besoin de plein
d'excipiants elle a besoin de packaging
enfin de cartonnage etc enfin comme
toute usine comme comment de pub pour
faire de la publicité est-ce que on a le
droit de faire de la publicité sur le
médicament
alors le pas sur le remboursable c'est à
dire que le médicament qui est à partir
du moment il est remboursé et pris en
charge par la collectivité la pub est
interdite la pub que tu peux avoir c'est
sur le remboursable le non remboursable
pardon nous remboursables s'épilote
c'est 5,5% du marché français donc je
t'en parle même pas
donc je reviens à mes lignes de prod le
choc de demande là c'est vraiment sur le
sur la question du paracétamol ça a été
un choc de demande c'est à dire que s'il
y a eu des tensions et tout c'est parce
que la demande l'augmentation de la
demande dans un temps court encore une
fois elle a été plus forte que la
capacité des industriels à s'adapter et
à augmenter leur production voilà un
autre exemple
tout à l'heure on était en train de
parler d'autre chose et
les masques il y avait pas de masques
qu'est-ce qu'on parlait non j'avais
envie de parler de oui de l'industrie
pharma parce qu'on emploie souvent le
terme et tout ça mais personne je pense
que il y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
savent ce que c'est parce que c'est
beaucoup de choses en fait les trucs
bien les métiers
ils font juste des produits qui
soulagent et qui sauvent des vies moi je
trouve ça pas mal après voilà je trouve
ça mieux que d'autres industries mais un
avis personnel En tant que patiente et
citoyenne française
alors l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est
en fait c'est c'est une myriade de
seniades une myriade de métier tu vas
commencer par la recherche tu peux avoir
des labos pharmaceutiques qui font qui
se spécialise en recherche parce que
c'est leur truc c'est là qu'ils sont
bons c'est là qu'ils ont leur valeur
ajoutée ils sont hyper bons pour trouver
et comment ça développer des molécules à
partir du moment où on commence à passer
par exemple en phase en phase de phase 3
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
envoyer le produit en licence à un autre
laboratoire qui lui va être spécialisé
pour la production industrielle et la
commercialisation voilà première étape
en France on a le pays de pasteur on a
pas réussi à développer un vaccin
anti-coïde avant tout le monde
idemment après tout le monde on a Sanofi
à mission de marché un vaccin qu'il a
positionné sur le rappel donc il sera
potentiellement un vaccin qui sera utile
un jour après qu'est-ce que ça m'a fait
moi écoute moi j'étais déjà bien
contente qu'on ait un vaccin assez tôt
un vaccin ARN en plus particulièrement
efficace
on peut pas gagner à tous les coups
enfin je veux dire la recherche c'est
quelque chose c'est quelque chose qui
est complexe c'est quelque chose qui
présente des aléas et c'est pas parce
que tu cherches que tu trouves et c'est
pas parce que tu cherches et que tu
cherches fort que tu trouves le premier
tu vois donc ça fait partie ça fait ça
fait partie ça fait partie des aléas de
la recherche et ce qui s'est passé
notamment sur le vaccin de Sanofi c'est
que il y a un moment où ils ont dû faire
un réajustement ils ont dû de ce que
j'ai entendu ils ont dû revenir et
repartir de zéro en phase 2 et ils ont
perdu un temps précieux à ce moment-là
privatisation de la recherche est-ce que
la recherche est-ce que laisser les
labos tout le temps chercher et breveter
des molécules est-ce que c'est pas
l'état de se réinvestir un peu plus
là-dedans
alors
j'ai un avis sur sur le rôle que devrait
prendre l'État mais pas forcément sur la
recherche si ça te va je reviendrai
là-dessus plus tard parce que là pour
l'instant on est encore vachement dans
le présent et
dans un second temps je pense que c'est
pas forcément il y a de la recherche
publique il y en a plein il y a beaucoup
de partenariats publics privés il y a
beaucoup de labos CNRS qui bossent avec
avec les labos et tout ça c'est pas
c'est pas un monde qui est complètement
séparés et il y en a de la recherche
publique donc je reviendrai je
reviendrai là dessus après si ça te si
ça te va je reviens sur mes métiers on a
la première étape qui est la recherche
ensuite tu as une autre étape qui va
être la chimie la production des des
principes actifs
notamment les principes chimiques les
principes actifs chimiques ça c'est un
métier vraiment à part c'est de la
chimie fine et c'est un métier très
spécifique ensuite tu vas avoir un autre
métier qui va être la formulation
ce qu'on appelle souvent ce qu'on
assimile à la production c'est à dire tu
as reçu ton ton Bull que ton fût de
principe actif et comment tu en fait je
t'en parlais tout à l'heure ce produit
qui va être administral à l'être humain
donc ça c'est l'étape de fabrication où
tu passes de ta poudre à ton comprimé
complet ensuite tu vas avoir l'étape de
conditionnement tu as fait tes comprimé
ou tellules et donc là ça va être la
mise en flacon ça va être la mise en
blister donc le blister c'est les les
petites comment dire les alvéoles avec
un film un film aluminium que vous
trouvez dans les boîtes de médicaments
conditionnement primaires celui qui est
en contact avec le médicament ensuite
conditionnement secondaire on rajoute la
notice on rajoute la boîte d'accord donc
ça c'est un autre métier et tu as encore
un autre métier après qui est la
distribution et la distribution
pharmaceutique je peux dire que c'est un
métier très très pointu c'est c'est des
chaînes qui sont extrêmement
performantes parce que sont des acteurs
qui ont une obligation de service public
qui doivent délivrer et livrer toutes
les pharmacies de France sans
distinction en 24 heures donc c'est un
vrai défi logistique ça c'est aussi un
autre métier et donc en fait tu vas
rentrer tu vas tu vas rencontrer tous
les quatre tu vas avoir des labos qui
sont hyper intégrés je pense à un labo
comme Sanofi par exemple c'est un bon
exemple labo français qui lui fait de la
recherche il a aussi des sites de
production chimiques de principes actif
il a aussi des sites de production de
produits de produits finits
conditionnement et il a même la
particularité d'avoir son ces sites sa
logistique particulière
ouais c'est bien après après on a aussi
plein d'acteurs qui sont hyper efficaces
sur leurs créneaux et en l'occurrence il
y a des prestataires qui se sont
développés à toutes les étapes de la
chaîne et on a aujourd'hui dans le
paysage français notamment beaucoup de
prestataires notamment sur la partie
production c'est ce qu'on appelle les
CDMO donc c'est les fabricants pour
tiers
et c'est quelque chose qui s'est
énormément développé ces derniers jours
c'est c'est en fait une mutation de
business model de l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui se recentre
finalement sur les activités qu'elle a
qui vont avoir potentiellement le plus
de valeur
j'ai une question internet
de frbn bonjour moi-même pharmacien
j'aimerais savoir quand est-ce que
l'État français va interdire
l'exportation par les grossistes
répartiteurs de médicaments destinés au
marché français avoir des médicaments
peu chers par rapport aux autres marchés
n'incite-t-il pas favoriser la création
de pénurie pour ceux voulant maximiser
les marges
merci
donc pour comprendre ça on va repartir
de la question du prix aujourd'hui en
France comme je vous disais les prix
sont administrés et il se trouve qu'ils
sont particulièrement peu cher et que
notamment parmi les moins chers au
niveau européen donc après on a des
analyses qui montrent des variations un
peu différentes des -19 - 21 %
du côté de du côté des industriels
pharmaceutiques qui parlent plutôt de
-39%. donc alors là on n'est pas dans le
cas de d'un côté la police et de l'autre
côté les manifestants parce que c'est
juste parce qu'en fait les analyses
souvent publics qui sont faites elles
sont faites sur des données publiques
c'est-à-dire sur des prix tarifs qui
sont en gros l'étiquette officielle tu
vois que le CEPS va donner aux
médicaments
le comité économique des produits de
santé celui qui fixe les prix et comme
je te disais tout à l'heure je suis pas
rentré dans le détail mais ça c'est un
contrat qui est passé on a un prix
facial mais en fait dans le contrat qui
est passé avec le laboratoire c'est ce
qu'on appelle un accord pris volume le
prix il est attribué par rapport à un
volume c'est-à-dire qu'on dit peau
globalement ton médicament la première
année on pense qu'il va soigner sans
patient et donc ce prix était attribué
par rapport à ce volume si jamais tu en
fais 150 hop remise derrière et donc en
fait c'est il y a un système de remise
qui est mis en place en plus c'est un
système de de ensuite de baisse de prix
et donc en fait ça ça relève du secret
des affaires cette contractualisation
entre le Comité économique et le
laboratoire donc souvent les études
publiques qui sont faites sur les
différences de prix elles sont basées
sur ces prix officiels et elles tiennent
pas compte de ces remises les
industriels du médicament au travers
leur cervicat ils ont publié d'autres
données avec leurs données qu'elles ont
cette qu'ils ont c'est-à-dire les ventes
réelles finalement si on retire les
remises qui font ensuite au Comité
économique et eux ils parlent plutôt
d'une différence de l'ordre de 39% en
moyenne donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui
en Europe dans un espace ouvert de
libre-échange avec un pays qui a des
médicaments qui qui sont beaucoup moins
chers que les voisins
ce qui peut poser problème
c'est le phénomène qu'on appelle
d'export parallèle donc on estime et ça
c'est à peu près on estime que à partir
d'une d'un différentiel de 15%, ça
commence à valeur le coût d'envoyer le
médicament à l'étranger parce que tu
dois quand même le reconditionner si tu
veux envoyer ton médicament français en
Allemagne il va quand même falloir
refaire le packaging avec sa notice en
allemand et tout ça mais c'est
effectivement un risque et donc ça
qu'est-ce que ça génère en fait ce
risque d'exportation parallèle ça génère
déjà des médicaments qui sont pas lancés
en France
et ça c'est une chose qu'on sait peu
mais sur les dernières années par
exemple sur tous les médicaments qui ont
été autorisés dans l'Union européenne tu
en as que 66% qui ont été commercialisés
en France alors ils étaient pas
forcément tous essentiels mais par
rapport à 92% en Allemagne il y en a une
certaine partie il y a des laboratoires
qui se disent je vais pas commercialiser
en France parce que je vais me pourrir
les marchés de microphones parce que je
sais que si je le vends 5 euros ici et
qu'il est 15 euros en Allemagne eh ben
les grossistes répartiteurs qui sont
propriétaires de leur stock qui achète
le médicament pour les revendre eux bah
est-ce qu'ils vont faire c'est qu'ils
vont prendre une partie et puis qui vont
aller le revendre et faire de la marge
en Allemagne donc c'est un risque qui
existe
comme je te disais il y a la question du
prix facial déjà qui permet d'essayer de
limiter aussi la différence la
différence faciale entre les prix
il y a des contingentements qui sont
faits aussi par les laboratoires pour
éviter justement ces exports parallèles
ils en ajustant de contingenté les
volumes qui mettent à disposition sur le
sur le marché français mais c'est
forcément effectivement quelque chose
qui est assez qui est assez délétère
c'est un truc que j'ai creusé j'ai
jamais trouvé de données alors personne
personne se vante apparemment de faire
des exports parallèles donc c'est des
données qu'on n'arrive pas à trouver on
sait que c'est un risque qui existe on
en parle mais personne se vendent de le
faire donc mais c'est sûrement on sait
que ça existe c'est sûr
et du coup il y a quand même des mesures
qui ont été qui ont été mises en place
c'est à dire que à partir du moment où
un médicament est à risque de tension ou
en tension surtout quand c'est MITM donc
les médicaments intérêts thérapeutiques
majeur à ce moment là les autorités de
santé ont la possibilité d'interdire les
exportations
oui oui si tu veux oui question quand
une tension imagine-toi que on est engué
on se reprend une épidémie bien sévère
sur la tête
on manque de pilule de traitement X pour
traiter la pathologie y en France en
France on n'arrive pas à se
s'approvisionner à l'étranger parce que
bon
les copains achètent plus cher que nous
donc ça vient pas chez nous comment on
fait pour distribuer le peu de stock
qu'on a on choisit les gens c'est un
tirage au sort c'est selon l'ordre
alphabétique c'est l'heure d'arrivée sur
le trottoir de l'hôpital quand on fait
la queue c'est la plaque est impair ou
si vous avez appelé le numéro vert avant
comment ça se passe alors ça c'est on a
déjà été confronté à ça et on est on est
encore confronté à ça
se passe
non en fait il y a des systèmes qu'on
appelle de contingentement en fait ce
qui sont qui sont mis en place
je suis en train de te trouver un il y a
un bon exemple pour ça c'est un produit
innovant c'est pas un produit générique
c'est un produit qui s'appelle le
bellatasept qui est un Mac qui est un
médicament anti rejet et
rejet de greffe et qui a une
particularité contrairement aux autres
médicaments anti-rogés c'est que c'est
qu'il l'attaque pas le rein enfin il
abîme pas le rein il provoque moins
d'hypertension et donc ce qui fait de
lui le médicament anti rejet de choix
pour ceux qui sont greffés du rein
donc particulièrement pour ses patients
là ça fait des années que il y a un
souci de production donc il y a eu un
changement d'usine qui à la base a
priori était pour pouvoir augmenter la
production et en fait c'est il y a plein
de problèmes dans l'usine alors je
connais pas du tout les détails de ce
qui se passe mais ça fait longtemps que
ce médicament est contingenté et ça pose
des vrais problèmes bah qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait tu as un compte un compte
gingembre général qui doit être géré
alors là je voudrais pas te dire de
bêtises je sais pas si c'est la DGS ou
la NSM qui gère ça et après au sein des
établissements sont les commissions
médicales d'établissement
et les médecins qui sont obligés de
faire un choix et ça c'est terrible on
l'a vu ça a traumatisé beaucoup de gens
pendant le covid qui sont obligés de
prioriser parce que ils savent que ils
ont x patients grefféréaux et que ils
ont pas de traitement pour tout le monde
donc ils sont obligés de ils sont
obligés de prioriser en fait
on fait un loto on tire la Courtepaille
c'est si tes vieux si ton espérance de
vie sur des critères médicaux
c'est des critères médicaux et je
connais pas le détail je pourrais pas te
dire je pense qu'après il doit y avoir
une question de gravité si tu veux
quelqu'un qui a déjà un abîmé on va
prioriser un anti rejet qui va moins lui
abîmer j'imagine que c'est ça c'est des
hypothèses ça c'est au médecin qu'il
faut demander je pense que après il faut
leur faire confiance là-dessus
donc tu vois ce que c'est une société
quand tu lui mets un petit sevrage
énergétique tu vois ce que ça fait quand
tu mets une société thermodustrielle en
petit sevrage énergétique les tensions
que ça peut créer avec les copains
limitrophes ou un peu plus loin le
système médicamenteux tu le sens
résilient en anticipation ça est-ce
qu'il déjà ils organisent des loto des
courtes pailles est-ce que tu les vois
bien se préparer à ça est-ce que tu vois
l'état consulter l'industrie
pharmaceutique en leur disant bah
écoutez les gars
cette année le prix du gaz ça va être au
taquet donc combien ça va sortir le prix
de vos pilules à la fin de l'usine
comment ça se passe les condrates les
contrats de fidélité on était avec vous
depuis des années où vous assuventionné
est-ce que vous allez continuer à vendre
aux copains vous allez rester chez nous
comment ça se passe est-ce que est-ce
que tu les sens bien ou tu les sens que
bon c'est chacun son
QI Dieu pour tous ou c'est c'est que
pourra est-ce que c'est le grand loto
pour pour pouvoir répondre à ça il faut
d'abord commencer par tirer le bilan de
là où on en est aujourd'hui et c'est
quoi c'est quoi les faiblesses et c'est
quoi les c'est quoi la challenge qu'on a
aux États-Unis ils ont une liste de
1300700 médicaments nécessaires en
France
c'est déjà de se dire c'est quoi
la fameuse liste des médicaments
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de
notre société
là
celle là elle est pas en préparation
pour moi il y en a une autre qui est en
préparation c'est les c'est les c'est
les M6 les msis les médicaments
stratégiques d'un point de vue
industriel et sanitaire
mes parents mes grands-parents ont payé
des impôts je paye des impôts mais
techniciens pays des impôts je me dis oh
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'argent
tous ces impôts c'est la moitié de notre
PIB c'est quoi ça doit être que des
impôts non il y a pas un Pékin lambda
un mec dans un bureau qui est payé
depuis des décennies ou un cabinet qui
est payé depuis des décennies pour
maintenir quand même comment tu dis la
liste les pistes
les médicaments stratégiques il y a pas
un Pékin
qui a pas été foutu de tenir cette liste
depuis des années où est-ce que ça
existait déjà et chaque année il l'a
complète mais non en fait
le truc c'est que je vais refaire un
point sur les vulnérabilité avant de se
dire on fait comment quand on se
projette en perspective contrainte mais
là on est en train de vivre une
inflexion dans notre monde ça fait des
années que on était dans une perspective
et d'une croyance d'abondance infinie
on n'avait pas besoin de définir ce
genre de liste on n'était pas du tout
dans cet état d'esprit on était dans
l'esprit de toujours plus on aura
toujours à disposition quoi qu'il arrive
et on pourra soigner toujours plus de
monde c'est l'objectif dans lequel on
était c'est l'infinité c'est l'infini
avec des lunettes roses et c'était vas-y
les Gaga c'est super cool vous inquiétez
pas en deux semaines
je ne suis pas dans leur tête et je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils prennent ce que je
veux dire c'est un point de vue sociétal
on est depuis très nombreuses décennies
dans une dans une croyance de l'infinité
de plein de choses l'infinité des
ressources de l'infinité du progrès avec
cette volonté de toujours plus toujours
plus toujours plus donc on ressentait
pas forcément le besoin de ça alors faut
savoir que depuis 77 il y a l'OMS qui a
réalisé qui a fait une liste qui a un
peu plus de 340 médicaments dessus qui
sont considérés comme des médicaments
essentiels qui sont pas forcément
adaptés correspondent pas forcément à la
fois aux besoins des patients français
et qui correspondent pas forcément à nos
protocoles aussi
de prise en charge donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui existait
en France on ne ressentait pas le besoin
de cette liste toi tu penses à cette
liste et tu as envie de la développer
parce que tu dis il va falloir qu'on
sécurise il faut qu'on sache par quoi
commencer parce que tu es déjà dans cet
état d'esprit ils étaient absolument pas
dans cet état d'esprit ça a commencé
au service de santé des armées t'envoies
une OPEX tu fais un stock
d'anticipes quel type de pathologie tu
es trop
forte exposées mais tu comptes tes
nombre de boîtes tu les envoies pas en
short en tant que sans Bob sans crème
solaire
qui est bien identifiée quand tu pars en
OPEX tu sais tu sais ce que tu sais ce
que tu vas avoir dans ta pharmacie et
tout ça là on parle la France comme un
camp de vacances
mais non non ce que je suis en train de
te dire c'est que la mentalité était
jusqu'à maintenant
pas adapter c'est à dire que on ne
pensait pas avoir besoin de ça ça a
commencé à bouger comme je te disais les
pénuries on était passé à 700 800 en
2018 ça a généré quoi ça généré une
mission d'information du Sénat ça a
commencé à chauffer
[Rires]
donc non mais ça a commencé à creuser
c'est à dire que ça a commencé à se dire
ça devient un petit peu inquiétant ce
phénomène qu'on a généré en dépouillant
littéralement les médicaments essentiels
en baissant leurs prix jusqu'à plus en
pouvoir
et depuis ce moment là les industriels
de pharmaceutique ne font que réclamer
une liste depuis ce moment-là ils disent
donnez-nous une liste des médicaments
essentiels sur lesquels il faut qu'on
focalise en
priorités
[Musique]
où ils ont il faut un petit peu d'argent
ce que tu me dis de baisser les
médicaments il baisse les médicaments ok
mais le chiffre d'affaires des grosses
boîtes qui produisent ces médicaments
c'est ce que je te disais tout à l'heure
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est une
myriade et à tous les titres de business
model aujourd'hui tu vas avoir des
laboratoires qui sont positionnés sur
des produits à très forte valeur ajoutée
sur lesquelles ils font de la recherche
et qui vont aller développer des
médicaments qui sont ciblés sur des
pathologies où il y a un gros un gros
besoin alors un besoin non satisfait et
pas forcément pour une grande quantité
de patience c'est-à-dire des des
médicaments pour lequel ils savent
qu'ils trouveront du financement et qui
pourront vendre très cher et à l'autre
bout de la chaîne tu vas avoir le
génériqueur qui te sort sa boîte par
exemple une boîte d'amoxicilline
aujourd'hui en prix fabricant
c'est-à-dire ce qui est payé à
l'industriel c'est un euro 16 je sais
pas si tu te rends compte 1 euro 16 une
boîte avec des comprimés de qualité
pharmaceutique dans un blister avec de
l'aluminium avec une notice avec une
boîte en carton c'est réalisé etc 1 euro
16 le prix d'une chocolatine globalement
[Rires]
donc tu vois 1 euro 16 tu imagines pour
un médicament quelque chose qui est une
qui est d'une qui est un niveau
d'exigence qualité qui est exceptionnel
donc on en est arrivé là donc tu as tous
les business models ces gens-là
aujourd'hui
les marges elles ne sont pas connues
c'est pas des choses sur lesquelles on
se sur lesquels c'est communiqué ce
qu'on sait en termes pas cher tu
comprends mais si ça marche à 40%
derrière je te dis pas du tout pas du
tout la preuve on en a un paquet ce que
je peux te dire c'est que par exemple
sur les formes pédiatriques aujourd'hui
exemple paracétamol tu vois
un de fabrique en français les formes
pédiatriques ils vont à perte
voilà on en est là c'est-à-dire qu'ils
font ils font des marges ils sont
arrivés à des niveaux ça fait ça fait 20
ans qu'il baisse les prix et ils s'en
sont arrivés à des niveaux qui sont
vraiment ras des pâquerettes et au
passage et au passage je vais te
rajouter au moment de la crise parce
qu'il y a une problématique de demande
ce laboratoire il a fait rapatrier
d'Italie un million de doses alors qu'en
Italie quand il les vend ses rentes
assez rentable il a fait revenir un
million de doses d'Italie pour les
vendre à perte pour pouvoir
approvisionner le marché français voilà
petite anecdote on en est
parce que sinon on va pas être crédible
revenons à la liste stratégique des
médicaments alors
on était j'en étais en 2018 2018 on
commence à s'affoler on commence à
s'inquiéter des pénuries il y a une
mission d'information du Sénat qui est
mise en place qui commence à s'en
inquiéter l'élaborateurs pharmaceutiques
qui disent mais dites nous faites-nous
une liste de médicaments et donc qui
n'existait pas on avait à cette époque
ce qu'on appelle les MITM donc les MITM
médicament d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur c'est 6000 médicaments
donc c'est pas ce qu'on appelle un choix
voilà c'est 40% de la pharmacopée
française c'est en groupe 13.000
médicaments donc j'appelle pas ça une
sélection voilà c'était mais l'idée
c'était d'identifier c'était du
déclaratif des industriels identifier
les médicaments qui citent à une
interruption de traitement tu peux avoir
une mise en cause du pronostic vital
pardon du patient à court moyen terme
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont suite
à ça ils ont mis une obligation de stock
en fait avant l'obligation de stock
c'était une semaine et c'est le cas pour
tous les autres médicaments pour les
MITM c'est deux mois de stock alors ce
qui est une bonne chose dans l'absolu
c'est dire que c'est jamais inutile
comme on parlait tout à l'heure de la
question de la flexibilité de de ces
chaînes logistiques complexes
pharmaceutiques ça fait toujours un
petit tampon supplémentaire pour
absorber un petit problème si par
exemple tu as un souci qualité et tu
retiens tes lots pendant un mois et tout
ça c'est c'est toujours c'est toujours
utile c'est pas des nuées de
conséquences
parce que ça son décou qui sont venus se
rajouter sur des médicaments sur
lesquels on avait déjà énormément tiré
les prix vers le bas donc des coûts de
structure en fait pour stocker les
produits sur le territoire français qui
sont venus se rajouter encore sur des
produits qui étaient déjà en grande
difficulté financière
donc suite au covid qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
nos gouvernants ont découvert
qu'effectivement il y avait un paquet de
principes actifs qui étaient qui étaient
fabriqués à l'étranger un paquet de
gouvernons ont découvert non 2021 2021
la mise en place de du stock c'était
post covid c'était pas post covid qui
sont dit on met en place des obligations
de stocks de deux mois qui peut être
étendu jusqu'à 4 mois dans des
circonstances particulières alors je me
réveille et à ce en parallèle en
parallèle tu avais la mise en place de
France relance qui a commencé déjà à
sponsoriser enfin vouloir subventionner
en tout cas des relocalisations à une
époque on n'avait pas encore travaillé
sur une liste prioritaire mais il y a
déjà un certain nombre de millions qui
ont été investis pour pour ces
problématiques là
cet effet je sais plus qui posait la
question de savoir est-ce qu'on envoie
les fruits on parle d'une filière
matériel donc 3 5 ans minimum avant de
pouvoir voir les fruits si on prend
l'exemple du paracétamol la
relocalisation de du principe actif et
considéré comme un enjeu il y a ouais il
y a un gros projet il y a un gros projet
qui a été mené avec nos deux acteurs
français qui sont Sanofi et ça et un
chimiste qui s'appelle séquence pour
justement relocaliser une partie de la
production de du principe actif sur le
sol français voilà c'est un des exemples
il y a franchement énormément d'argent
qui qui est mis qui est mis sur cette
problématique là la DGE travail à fond
oui oui en franchement ça ça fait partie
vraiment des bénéfices du covid la
claque a été très très forte et il y a
une prise de conscience énorme de ces
vulnérabilités et du besoin et ils sont
vraiment en train de mettre beaucoup
beaucoup de moyens pour la
relocalisation en France et en Europe
après
qui a été
salvatrice si je comprenais
quand on voit tes bidasses sur le
terrain que tu leur files pas de balle
ça fait quoi ça fait des morts s'ils
peuvent pas s'ils peuvent pas répliquer
s'ils sont tirer dessus si tu les
envoies en short et en tongs moi je vais
te demander je vais te le montrer là tu
as pas l'impression que il fallait
attendre 2021 pour se réveiller que bon
bah la santé c'est quand même un secteur
stratégique on sait jamais on voit les
militaires faire des exercices
nucléaires bactériologiques et chimiques
en France les gars c'est cool non mais
est-ce que tu comprends
non c'est pas des baraques c'est juste
c'est et là je suis complètement
d'accord avec toi c'est un constat que
moi je fais en travaillant là-dessus
c'est que on a laissé au secteur privé
notre système de soins alors on a pas
l'impression parce que hôpitaux publics
parce que parce que prise en charge par
la collectivité etc la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui les éléments qui sont
essentiels à la pratique de nos
professionnels de santé qui sont on
parle de médicament mais il y a aussi
tous les dispositifs médicaux
aujourd'hui ce sont des produits
d'entreprises privées
c'est à dire qu'on a privatisé une
partie une partie des soins donc on a
laissé et notamment les médicaments qui
sont les plus essentiels on les a
laissés aux mains de du marché en fait
et donc de la mondialisation et donc de
l'optimisation de tous les coups etc
on a laissé ça privatiser et tu peux
faire exactement le même parallèle avec
la question de l'alimentation
aujourd'hui notre alimentation
elle est dans les mains de structures
privées alors quand tu prends une
société ce qui fait une société ce qui
fait la stabilité et la solidité d'une
société c'est trois essentiels c'est la
sécurité l'alimentation et la santé
sur deux de ces trois critères
aujourd'hui on a laissé la main pour
l'essentiel au secteur privé bon petite
parenthèse je suis d'accord avec toi et
j'aimerais bien que la santé ça
redevienne vraiment un secteur
stratégique avec tout ce que ça implique
en fait en faire un secteur
quand tu vois la défiance qu'il y a on
entend des mots des éléments langage sur
Internet Big Pharma
à gauche à droite les gens sont défiance
face à notre pharmacopée de nos
industriels
pour les rassurer il faut leur dire quoi
et est-ce qu'ils ont raison de
s'inquiéter on voit des milliards de
milliards en temps d'amende on voit des
phases de test
1 2 3
de temps en temps à lava comme je te
pousse
hein on est d'accord non on n'est pas
d'accord je pense que le système
d'évaluation du médicament aujourd'hui
il est quand même vraiment solide et ça
pas toujours été le cas on n'a pas fait
de petites histoires mais
si ça t'intéresse jusque jusqu'au début
du 20e siècle enfin c'est à partir du
début du 20e siècle à partir de 1937 par
exemple la seule chose qui était demandé
pour pour un nouveau médicament c'était
d'évaluer sa sécurité c'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment où tu avais montré qu'a
priori le médicament tu es pas
globalement il pouvait être lancé et on
considérait que l'évaluation de
l'efficacité elle devait se faire de
façon empirique par les médecins avec
tous les pieds que ça comporte
ça a duré pendant quelques temps ça
s'est bien passé
voilà médiator était pas né loin de là
en 1950 était arrivé la crise du
talidomyl je passe du temps à rappel
donc thalidomine c'était
ça a été une crise importante puisque
c'était en fait un médicament qui était
qui était prescrit qui est donné pour
les pour les femmes enceintes en début
de grossesse pour limiter les nausées et
il se trouve que c'est un produit qui
est extrêmement toxique extrêmement
tératogène et qui a provoqué donc des
faucomellies dans des déformations des
morts initiaux et beaucoup de
déformations chez les fœtus on a mis un
petit moment à s'en rendre compte ça a
été un scandale sanitaire énorme et
suite à ça
suite à ça alors en plus ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les États-Unis ont
été hyper leaders justement sur toute
cette évolution de l'évaluation du
médicament et les États-Unis n'avaient
pas autorisé ce produit parce qu'il y
avait une personne à l'époque à
l'évaluation qui avait vu les résultats
et qui avait dit je le sens pas trop ce
médicament qui était lancé en Europe et
a dit non aux États-Unis on va faire
faire attention et elle a eu bien raison
et donc elle a sauvé probablement
beaucoup d'enfants américains et donc ça
a été un énorme scandale on s'est rendu
compte de ça et c'est ce scandale qui a
conduit ensuite à la mise en place à
partir de 1962 aux États-Unis de ce
système que je viens de te décrire c'est
à dire de l'obligation pour les
industriels de démontrer sécurité et
efficacité du médicament et plus
seulement la sécurité et surtout ça a
été la mise en place de ce qu'on appelle
la pharmacovigilance parce que tout à
l'heure je me suis arrêté au niveau de
la ML ton médicament il est utilisé mais
son évaluation elle s'arrête jamais un
médicament on sait c'est toujours un
compromis quoi qu'il arrive même celui
qui te paraît le plus inoffensif etc un
médicament c'est toujours un compromis
sur un bénéfice et tu as potentiellement
un risque alors après ce risque au
niveau de l'individu il va se manifester
il va pas se manifester et il y a plus
ou moins de risques qui se manifeste
mais c'est toujours un compromis et ce
médicament tout au long de sa vie il
sera toujours observé évalué par par la
pharmacovigile en sorte tu as des études
aussi de phase 4 qui peuvent se faire
après la mise sur le marché notamment
pour regarder comment ça se passe dans
la vraie vie parce que nous on l'a
évalué dans le cadre d'un protocole et
après faut voir quand on met à
disposition de tout le monde est-ce que
tout le monde l'utilise bien comme il
faut est-ce que c'est bien dans le cadre
dans lequel il a été autorisé et puis
parce que tu as aussi un effet d'échelle
c'est à dire que même si ton médicament
qui est destiné à beaucoup de patients
en face froid tu l'as testé sur 10000
patients ton effet indésirable qui va
sortir une fois sur un million tu es
d'accord qu'il y a des chances pour que
tu l'aies pas vu
donc voilà donc il y a toujours un effet
d'échelle et c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu
aussi des histoires de médicaments qui
ont été retirées du marché donc pour
certains se rappellent peut-être du Diox
qui était un anti-inflammatoire qui a
été qui a été retiré du marché quelques
années après il y a eu d'autres cas
comme ça c'était des choses qu'on
pouvait pas prévoir et qui sont arrivés
à partir du moment où les médicaments
ont été utilisés beaucoup plus largement
c'est pas une question c'est si c'est
une question
d'Eric depuis la campagne présidentielle
de 2012 Mélenchon demande un pôle public
du médicament comment croire qu'il
découvre sa post covid
c'est pas qui découvre alors
on va reparler de ça parce que je suis
assez d'accord avec cette proposition
c'est pas qu'il découvre c'est juste
qu'il voulait pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gouvernants qu'on a
ils sont dans une idéologie qui est
libérale
que même si notre président a déclaré
c'est la fin de l'abondance je suis pas
sûr qu'il est bien saisi ce que ça
voulait dire et le changement d'état
d'esprit que ça devrait en fait
générer dans la gestion de la gestion
des ressources dans la gestion de notre
pays
la bourbouche est finie la descente est
difficile
et donc pour revenir tout à l'heure sur
les problématiques avant de se poser la
question de si tu colles là-dessus des
perspectives contraintes donc on a vu
qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a on a on
a en gros
de marché on va avoir des médicaments de
pointe des médicaments innovants pas
tous mais globalement oui
je m'intéresse au remboursable je te
parle de ça comme je te disais le non
remboursable c'est 5,5% je pense que
c'est pas l'objet du débat et puis de
toute façon c'est pas pris en charge par
la collectivité mais globalement tu vas
avoir deux types de médicaments donc ces
médicaments innovants qui sont souvent
très chers
les plus récents et aussi parce que ça
va aller traiter une pathologie rare
avec juste quelques patients et tout ça
donc un peu une production de luxe et de
l'autre côté tu as une grande masse de
médicaments qui sont particulièrement
importants et qui aujourd'hui va
quasiment plus rien
et sur lesquels il y a un vrai risque
parce que il y a une compétition
croissante au niveau de la demande
mondiale de ces produits là et que c'est
des produits qu'on a pas sécurisé parce
que ils sont fabriqués à l'autre bout du
monde et probablement pas en quantité
suffisante etc donc il y a un vrai enjeu
si tu veux tu as vraiment deux mondes
aujourd'hui
qui se qui cohabitent avec un qui a
nourri d'autres pendant très très
longtemps et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui
et Kang à tel point petite anecdote que
cette année c'est la première fois que
le syndicat des représentants des
génériques a refusé de participer au
négociations annuelles avec le comité
économique de santé ils ont refusé de
venir ils en sont arrivés à un point ça
fait des années qui disent c'est c'est
plus possible c'est plus possible on se
retrouve dans le rouge sur plein de
produits on commence à vendre à perte
etc ils étaient pas entendus cette année
ils ont dit on vient même pas voilà pour
marquer le coup il y a il y a un
moratoire quand même qui a été qui a été
mis en place là sur pour arrêter les
baisses de les baisses de prix
dégénériques c'est bien c'est un bon
début quand il y a à côté de ça
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la masse
c'est-à-dire la masse ce qui ce qui
traite le plus de monde c'est-à-dire
c'est c'est les c'est ces médicaments
qui pour la plupart sont sortis c'est
les médicaments du XXe siècle de la
deuxième partie du 20e siècle ce sont
ceux-là qui qui servent le plus ce qui
va le plus grand chose aujourd'hui et
donc j'en reviens à ta question des
listes puisqu'on avait pas fini
d'aborder le sujet
juste un truc c'est qu'il y a un
médicament qui est pas assez rentable il
faut arrêter de le produire
comment ça est-ce que il faut mettre de
la rentabilité à la santé alors si c'est
si c'est une boîte privée qui le
fabrique
je veux dire si elle continue elle va
mourir on est d'accord hein donc ça pose
la valeur
autant augmenter son prix
facial donc je reviens sur la question
d'hélice parce qu'on n'avait pas terminé
ce point là donc
depuis 2018 les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques disaient mes données
nous une liste de médicaments essentiels
et tout ça ce qui s'est passé c'est que
du coup post covid ils ont commencé à
travailler sur un projet les fameux msis
dont je te parlais tout à l'heure
qui sont découvert en 2021 qu'ils ont
commencé à mettre en place en 2021 mais
avec un objectif c'est à dire que ces
listes là elle a été pensée avec un
objectif de relocalisation
France relance France 2030 on a pris on
a pris conscience de nos vulnérabilités
on commence à réaliser que la santé
s'était un peu importante et donc et
donc non mais franchement il y a
énormément de moyens qui sont mis
j'étais en contact avec la DGE sur plein
d'aspects et franchement ils sont ils
sont à fond alors ok c'est peut-être
trop tard et trop peu mais je trouve ça
très bien déjà que ça que ça ait des
marré et donc en fait les msis c'est
quoi l'objectif c'est l'objectif de
relocalisation donc comment est-ce
qu'ils font cette liste ils partent de
un besoin médical c'est à dire que tu as
une première étape de tri qui va se
faire au niveau ansm DGS qui ont
consulté les sociétés savantes
des principales des principales
spécialités médicales donc là en
l'occurrence ils ont commencé le travail
la fameuse liste des 48 que vous êtes
peut-être vu passer dans la presse ils
ont commencé avec l'anesthésie réa Longo
et la cardio c'est quand même plus plus
voilà plus ils ont rajouté trois
médicaments de crise d'urgence mais
alors oui alors c'est pas mal et en même
temps
ça peut aider non
je suis pas sûre qu'un coup de marteau
sur la tête ça puisse aider
globalement le truc c'est que l'objectif
de cette liste pour être raisonnable
c'était entre 200 et 300 médicaments là
on en est à 48 avec trois spécialités et
trois spécialités médicales seulement
donc je pense qu'il y a un mois il va
falloir peut-être à choisir un peu plus
mais tu as ce premier filtre c'est à
dire que tu consultes tu dis voilà d'un
point de vue médical avec les sociétés
savantes c'est quoi les médicaments qui
sont les plus importants pour vous et
après tu as un deuxième filtre et ce
deuxième filtre c'est unsm avec DGE et
là c'est le filtre industriel c'est à
dire que pour ces produits qui ont été
sélectionnés par les médecins ils
évaluent la vulnérabilité en fait de la
chaîne de production c'est à dire qu'il
regarde comment je peux rajouter un
paramètre qui est pas dans leur
sélection mais oui
cette fameuse liste elle a été faite
dans quel type de contrainte
est-ce qu'il a été faite dans 3% de
croissance 10% de récession
c'est la liste
il faut leur téléphoner maintenant c'est
maintenant qu'ils sont en train de la
faire
leur scénario de liste
ultime conquête problème c'est sur quels
critères parce que
aujourd'hui on est dans une réflexion et
je te remercie le soulever parce que
c'est c'était le point quand je te
disais je pense que la liste qu'il nous
faut elle est toujours pas en
préparation
leur point est aujourd'hui assez
statique c'est à dire que cette deuxième
étape ils font une évaluation la
vulnérabilité industrielle c'est-à-dire
qu'ils regardent ces produits que les
médecins ont sélectionnés ils disent bon
le principe actif il vient d'où est-ce
qu'il vient que de que d'une usine
quelque part dans le monde ou est-ce que
c'est plusieurs acteurs est-ce qu'il y
en a au moins en Europe en France et
tout ça ils évaluent ensuite la
vulnérabilité de la production donc du
principe actif mais aussi de la partie
formulation est-ce qu'il y en a un peu
en Europe ou est-ce qu'on est très
dépendant et tout ça donc ils appliquent
un second filtre
et en découle ensuite ces produits ce
que ça veut dire ça ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui un produit qui pourrait être
médicalement essentiel mais dont le
principe actif est en moi en partie déjà
produit en France ou en Europe ou
fabriquer en France et en Europe ne sera
pas dans cette liste il va être sorti de
cette liste puisqu'il va pas être
prioritaire pour des projets de
relocalisation c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui la liste des médicaments
essentiels pour la santé d'un maximum de
français elle n'existe toujours pas ça
c'est une première chose ensuite on va
parler et ça c'est quelque chose qui me
gêne moi beaucoup c'est que on est à ma
connaissance toujours sur une évaluation
statique là on est en train de parler de
filière industrielle on est en train de
parler d'investissement à 10 20 ans on
est en train de parler d'usine qui met
des années à se monter surtout que la
pharma
quantité de validation derrière etc donc
c'est des processus très longs c'est à
dire que de mon point de vue ce dont on
manque c'est de prospective c'est-à-dire
que il faudrait aujourd'hui se poser et
se dire ok de quoi ont besoin les
Français aujourd'hui mais surtout de
quoi ils vont avoir besoin dans 5 ans
dans 10 ans dans 20 ans et ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut se poser la question de
à quoi ressemblera la France l'état de
la France dans cinq ans dans 10 ans dans
20 ans et traduire ça en besoins
sanitaires
mais est-ce qu'il faut aussi se remettre
les yeux en face des trous par rapport à
nos capacités de santé c'est à dire que
nos finances publiques bon on est à 3000
milliards de dettes
on se bat on se bat on y croit mais
est-ce qu'il faut aussi être réaliste
c'est à dire que il faut aussi baisser
notre degré d'exigence
c'est à dire qu'on va moins bien soigner
on aura moins de médicaments
on n'aura pas les derniers traitements
où est-ce qu'il faut refuser de le dire
et croire encore que tout va bien
pense pas à moi de dire ce qu'il faut
faire je vais te dire ce qui me paraît
être pertinent en tout cas
la première chose c'est cette
anticipation là dont je te parlais on a
on a des équipes tu vois la rétine qui a
travaillé sur des scénarios je pas ma
connaissance en tout cas c'est scénarios
n'ont pas été transposés en qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire comme besoin sanitaire
en besoin qui sont pas de la communauté
de la rétine donc
pour faire des scénarios c'est ça
j'aurais pas présenté ça comme ça mais
en tout cas
c'est une initiative du ministère des
armées qui a réuni un certain nombre de
d'auteurs de science-fiction enfin de
d'écrivain et tout ça pour les faire
travailler sur des scénarios
prospectifs possibles pour la France à
horizon 2030 c'est ça je crois et il y a
un certain nombre de scénarios qui sont
ressortis je les ai pas tous lu il y a
des cernes qui sont très intéressants et
je pense que il y a beaucoup de
activités et qu'il y a aussi des bases
qui sont très pertinentes dans les dans
la façon dont ça a été construit de
toute façon aujourd'hui on sait que
l'armée elle se prépare à un certain
nombre de choses ce qui serait
intéressant ce serait que ces scénarios
on les transforme en besoins sanitaires
qu'on les transforme en besoin de
médicaments ça sera ça serait la
première étape parce que c'est ce dont
on a besoin on aura besoin dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans qu'il faut aujourd'hui
sécuriser en priorité donc cette notion
de sécurisation et de et de
relocalisation
de toute façon elle peut elle se fera à
l'échelle européenne c'est illusoire de
penser qu'on va pouvoir localiser tous
les principes actifs tous les
médicaments en France c'est quelque
chose qui doit se faire dans une dans le
cas d'une coopération européenne surtout
quand la France devient une puissance de
moyenne impuissance
il faut compter sur ses copains
oui après c'est de toute façon je pense
que quand la situation se tend on a
intérêt à resserrer les liens avec les
voisins c'est mon point de vue et je
pense que ça c'est une bonne façon de le
faire avec le covid on se tape assez sur
le tarmac pour avoir des masques mini
China
extraordinaire
d'évolution c'était pas très beau ça je
suis d'accord avec toi que c'était pas
très beau ce qui s'est passé
son stock à jour il a dû se battre en
premier pour éviter de se faire virer
par son patron
je pense que je pense non mais justement
je pense que d'un point de vue sécurité
d'un point de vue géopolitique il y a
une carte à jouer qui me paraît énorme
c'est à dire que si on a cette capacité
d'anticiper et de se dire la France et
l'Europe de demain ça va être quoi on
sait on sait que on n'a pas de capacité
anticiper alors si on pouvait faire ça
on va anticiper la pluie je pense qu'on
en est capable en tout cas on va on va
on va pas deviner l'avenir mais je pense
qu'on est capable de définir un certain
nombre de scénarios qui sont tout à fait
pertinents on pourra pas choisir mais
déjà d'avoir des scénarios et de se dire
qu'est-ce que comment ça se transforme
en besoin ça voudrait dire attends tu me
laisses pas finir tu me laisses pas
finir
ça marche pas on s'expose à quoi en fait
on s'expose à des gens qui sont pas
soignés on s'expose à des pathologies
qui dégénèrent on s'expose à quoi si tu
as un cancer qui est pas traité et que
tu as une métastase osseuse qui vient se
balader dans ton organisme tu crois que
le politique ta pote en rapport au vide
attendre pour lui dire écoute coco je
comprends pas bien pourquoi je paye des
impôts depuis des années alors qu'il y a
pas d'antidouleur ou que vous m'avez
laissé tellement dans la mouise que ça à
métastasé de partout tu comprendras que
je peux pas te répondre si je ne sais
pas qu'est-ce qui restera parce que là
en fait ce qui est en train de se jouer
maintenant c'est ce qu'on est en train
de sécuriser et c'est ce qu'on va
sécuriser maintenant qu'il permettra de
déterminer qu'est-ce qu'on peut prendre
en charge demain et donc en fait cette
prospective elle est pour moi vraiment
stratégique parce que si on est vraiment
bon si on choisit même au sein de
l'Union européenne si on est stratège et
qu'on choisit les bons médicaments c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait
potentiellement nous protéger d'un point
de vue géostratégique de devenir des
fournisseurs essentiels après sur ta
question
si tu me permets je vais revenir en
arrière et refaire un petit peu
d'histoire et de se dire
globalement si tu reprends l'histoire de
la santé de l'humanité
de la révolution néolithique au milieu
du XVIIIe siècle à 1750 l'espérance de
vie c'était globalement 25 ans 25 30
avec des petites variations fonction des
crises des guerres des choses comme ça
à partir de 1750 de 1750 à 1950
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a doublé
cette expérience de vie
on est arrivé à une moyenne enfin une
espérance de vie à peu près 60 ans
comment comment
non je parle d'espérance de vie c'est la
résultante c'est la résultante qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé pendant cette période là
ce qui s'est passé ça a été le donc là
je vais je fais référence au travaux de
d'un épidémiologue qui s'appelle
Jean-David Zeitoun que je vous conseille
qui est fait un travail absolument
exceptionnel qui a écrit deux livres qui
sont passionnants et donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette période
traitement traitement des villes donc
c'est à dire assainissement eau potable
ensuite ça a été l'alimentation c'est à
dire qu'on a développé notre capacité à
extraire des calories de l'environnement
avec avec l'agriculture et les tout
début de la médecine ça a été c'était
quelques vaccins globalement s'arrête
quand tu arrives en poste de deuxième
guerre mondiale 1950 tu as deux deux
trois antibiotiques qui se battent en
duel et on avait déjà un certain nombre
de vaccins qui avaient commencé à
développer au 19e siècle ce que je veux
dire c'est que
on faisait exactement
et à cette époque là je crois qu'il y
avait la toute première chimiothérapie à
cette époque là il y avait quand même un
cancer sur trois qui guérissait
et on était juste sur chimio radio
thérapie d'accord donc pour te donner
une idée
1950 l'humanité de faire les Français en
tout cas avec déjà une espérance de vie
d'environ 60 ans alors que la pharmacie
moderne c'était pas encore développée
l'espérance de vie
du cadre ou de l'ouvrier
entre les 5% les plus riches et 5% les
plus pauvres c'est très Ampe différence
de l'espérance de vie aujourd'hui mais
globalement dis toi qu'avant la
pharmacie industrielle à cette époque là
on avait déjà à peu près 60 ans de
d'espérance de vie
ce que ce que ce qu'a apporté la
pharmacien industrielle jusqu'à
maintenant c'est en gros 20 ans
supplémentaires on sait déjà tout ça
pouvez-vous répondre aux questions
concernant le futur c'est à dire que sur
l'espérance de vie l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie l'augmentation des
techniques chirurgicales augmentation
des capacités de traitement la
diversification des monicules la
recherche qu'on sait tout ça déjà si on
rentre en récession que on peut plus
payer tout ça ça va faire quoi ça va
baisser l'espérance de vie ça va avoir
une médecine à triple vitesse à
quintuple vitesse tout dépend à quelle
vitesse est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
descend la vraie question c'est
de quoi on va manquer c'est pour ça que
Madame démonstration c'était de dire
aujourd'hui il faut pas se dire à tous
crever à 30 ans parce que on avait déjà
une espérance de vie de 60 ans à une
certaine époque où on n'avait pas encore
forcément toute cette pharmacie moderne
après le monde était différent
c'est-à-dire que il y avait un certain
nombre de risques qui n'était pas encore
présent depuis cette époque là on
l'humanité quand même bien empoisonné
avec des produits chimiques avec
l'arrivée de l'agro-industrie des
aliments hyper transformés qui sont très
très délétères pour pour la santé mais
globalement on a passé l'air microbienne
où tout le monde mourait d'infection on
est passé à 1h ou des gens en 1950 on
mourait de pathologies cardiovasculaires
et en mourraient de cancer et c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui le risque
qu'il y a dans le futur et ça c'est
encore une question d'hypothèse c'est à
dire que si on ne sécurise pas ce qu'on
est en train de commencer à faire si on
ne sécurise pas les traitements les plus
essentiels on pourrait revenir à cette
air microbienne c'est-à-dire que les
infections pourraient revenir en plus
des épidémies émergentes que notre mode
de vie favorise aujourd'hui on est
rentré dans l'air des pandémie et on
sait pourquoi c'est c'est parce que
c'est à cause de la pression qu'on met
notamment sur la sur la biodiversité et
parce que nous organismes aussi sont
affaiblis donc ça c'est un risque c'est
à dire que si on ne travaille pas là
dessus effectivement
il pourrait y avoir ce retour c'est pour
ça que ce qui me paraît important c'est
de se dire il faut de la prospective il
faut se dire c'est quoi les médicaments
qu'on veut cibler alors les médicaments
essentiels qu'on veut sécuriser mais
c'est aussi qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
innovation
vers quel sens
la question qu'il faut se poser
aujourd'hui c'est c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
va vouloir traiter c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir besoin de
traiter la prospective d'abord elle peut
nous dire ce sera quoi les besoins de
demain est-ce qu'on sera dans un
contexte conflictuel est-ce qu'on sera
dans un contexte on sait qu'on aura des
infections des infections émergentes ça
c'est sûr et donc se dire aujourd'hui
c'est ça qu'il faut sécuriser et c'est
là dessus qu'il faut miser en termes
d'innovation parce que de l'innovation
on aura toujours besoin et des capacités
d'innovation notamment des capacités de
production de vaccins sur lesquels on
travaille beaucoup et c'est ça qui
demain pourra faire une énorme
différence dans un monde contraint ça
aurait été notre capacité à anticiper ce
qu'on aura besoin de traiter ce dont on
va mourir demain parce que si on fait
pas ce travail là on pourra pas le
savoir est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à la communauté
trois bouquins un conseil à la
communauté ouais je vais commencer par
un auteur je viens d'en parler Jean
David Zeitoun qui est gastro-entérologue
et épidémiologue qui a écrit deux livres
qui sont super donc la grande extension
et le suicide de l'espèce qui sont hyper
inspirants pour comprendre l'histoire de
la santé humaine et les risques de notre
de notre population de notre santé
actuelle
un deuxième bouquin j'aurais envie de
proposer l'énergie du déni de Vincent
vignerons donc président fondateur
d'adrastia
parce que Vincent il a ce il a ce talent
il a cette capacité à poser les
questions qui fâchent
à poser les questions qui dérangent
parfois et donc il a l'honnêteté de
présenter ça comme les hypothèses mais
en tout cas lui il questionne la
question de la transition énergétique il
se pose de la question de est-ce que la
transition énergétique existe vraiment
est-ce qu'on n'est pas juste en train
d'additionner et est-ce qu'on risque pas
au contraire de potentialiser finalement
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles donc
je trouve ça je trouve ça très très
intéressant et très comment dire
inspirant de se poser des questions
fondamentales sur ces questions que qui
paraissent qui paraissent évidentes et
pourtant qui n'ont jamais été démontré
par la science
et un troisième
j'ai envie de proposer une BD pour
changer un peu une BD que qui m'a
beaucoup touchée qui s'appelle la maison
de Roberto Innocenti
on n'a pas eu l'occasion de parler de
complexité et de beaucoup de choses
c'est dommage mais notamment de
d'autonomie et d'hétéronomie cette BD
c'est l'histoire d'une maison au cours
du XXe siècle ça commence en 1900 et
c'est très peu de texte mais beaucoup
d'images et on voit en fait l'évolution
de cette maison et c'est un livre qu'on
peut lire plusieurs fois on trouvera
d'autres détails à chaque fois qu'on va
le relire et c'est je trouve une
expression
artistique super claire de comment
est-ce que notre mode de vie a évolué
d'une forme d'autonomie d'un lien avec
avec nos besoins primaires et
fondamentaux à l'hétéronomie qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui c'est à dire c'est
pas les gens hyper hors-sol qui sont
très déconnectés de leurs besoins
fondamentaux et je trouve que c'est une
BD qui illustre ça très très bien parce
que tu as un conseil pour les jeunes
générations oui un conseil pour les
jeunes générations apprenez le vivant
apprenez le vivant parce que parce
qu'apprendre le vivant ça vous permettra
de comprendre ce qui va se passer ça
vous permettra de mieux vous adapter
ça peut se faire de plein de façons
différentes ça peut être choisir des
voies de d'agriculture choisir des voies
de soins pharmaciens par exemple pour
prêcher pour ma paroisse on manque
énormément de de pharmacien et de
techniciens dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique qu'on a envie de
relocaliser mais encore faudrait-il
qu'on est qu'on est les ressources pour
ça ça peut être médecin ça peut être
vétérinaire enfin il y a plein de façons
aujourd'hui je pense de vraiment
apprendre et s'intéresser aux vivants
parce que c'est ça qui va compter demain
parce qu'on aura toujours besoin je
pense de gens qui qui le comprennent le
vivant qui vont être capable de
s'adapter et qui vont être capables de
de composer avec malgré tous les
changements qui qui se profile et s'il
vous plaît ne choisissez pas toutes les
voix qui se nourrissent de la complexité
de notre société
[Musique]